This is Jocko podcast number
59 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
Okay.
Their screams are the worst.
We're more than a hundred meters
away on the other side of the river,
but I can hear marines dying.
Their armored vehicle hit a landmine.
Yeah,
it caught fire with 15 men aboard.
Okay.
They scream as they burn alive.
The radio chatter is desperate.
Almost a sterically.
Okay.
Nobody can get to them.
There will be no salvation,
only a torturous death in the flames
from our position across the river,
we hear every agonizing moment and can
see their funeral pyre rising over the
river bank.
I can do nothing.
Okay.
It is the most helpless enraging
feeling I've ever experienced.
I have no way to get across
the water to those burning men.
Okay.
It takes forever for the
last screams to fade away.
Yeah.
And that is an excerpt from a
book called Heart for the fight.
Okay.
And it's written by a
guy named Brian Stan,
and if you don't know who Brian Stann is,
you can Google him.
Okay.
He's a son,
a father or husband.
He was the WEC light heavyweight
champion of the world.
He's a UFC veteran.
Yeah.
11 fights in the UFC with some wins and
some losses against some of the best
fighters in the world.
He's also a veteran of the
United States Marine Corps
with two tours to Iraq as a platoon
commander and as a company XL.
And I am honored tonight to actually
have Brian with us here as a guest.
Yeah,
Mr Brian Stann welcome to the
show. I got to tell you, that's a,
I have not been introduced
like that before at an exit
of that book that I could
honestly say I haven't laid eyes on,
I don't even know how many years.
I forget the year we released
it. Some powerful writing by, uh,
my ghost writer Jon Bruning. And
that is a tough, tough memory.
It's one of those ones that we kind of
buried deep down and think about just
from time to time. But, uh,
certainly when you, when you,
at times where maybe you take
things for granted in life,
it's good to go back to that moment.
You know, and realize that a,
whenever I may be whining
about or whatever I think
is difficult at the time is
a heck of a lot easier than it once was.
And I need to be grateful,
get off my butt and go
finish. Yeah. I think that
a lot of people, you know, you get,
you see the explosions take
place with ideas and you know,
the wars that we were involved
in were, you know, the,
the main weapon of the enemy was the IED.
And even when we made thicker,
heavier armored vehicles or like track
vehicles when they get hit with an IED,
even though it might withstand some of
the impact, there's fires start and it's,
it's a nightmare. And this is the
nightmare you describe right there. And
okay.
You know,
I want to get into that.
I want to get into the
combat that you experienced.
But before we do that, first of all,
like the people that listen to this show,
not everyone even watches UFC,
not everyone knows about you.
So just kind of give a
little bit of a background
on grown up. Let's take it back to
Scranton. Chevy. Yeah, absolutely.
Uh,
so moved around a lot.
I was actually sells born in Japan and uh,
around that time when,
when my mom had come back to the states,
my father had left and so grew
up in northeast Pennsylvania.
We moved around quite a bit,
uh,
but got into sports in the early age.
And I had a phenomenal mom and,
and I think not having a dad really
affected my sister a lot more than it
affected me.
Um,
but even from an early age,
I,
I knew that the military was going to
be an option from the days of being a
young kid watching silly movies like
Iron Eagle, you know, they were,
they were something, they were not called
Iron Eagle. Silly in front of that.
That's not your classic.
Yep. But, but for me there,
there was always something to it that,
that rang is special to me.
And you know,
what I found is growing up without a dad,
you tend to want to impress every
male influence you have in your life.
So every time I went out for a team,
I wanted to be the hardest
worker on the team.
I'd run through a wall for my coach and,
and,
and that continued all the
way through high school.
And then all of a sudden
playing high school football,
I started to get recruited by some good
schools and not many people in my family
had gone to college.
Certainly I had expected to go to college
but never expected to get recruited to
go play somewhere. And so that
was a different experience for me.
I didn't always handle it the best.
Um,
but when the naval academy came knocking,
you know,
I knew that's what I wanted to go.
West Point started recruiting me
early as a junior, I took my films,
my tapes to the Naval Academy.
There was just something about that
place and I wanted to go there.
So I decided before I make a decision,
let me visit West Point,
let me visit the Naval Academy
and a four day time period,
I'll visit both and make my decision.
When I went to West Point,
one of the football coaches was
supposed to meet me there never showed.
So one of the players took me
around campus, showed me some stuff,
but it was still beautiful. I
mean greater than any, you know,
Scranton's one of the poorest
cities in America. It's not nice.
So you know, my uncles,
my aunts and my mom,
the thought of me going to
the naval came as a big deal.
I remember my track coach in high
school telling me, Brian, listen,
this is a big deal.
It's a great opportunity.
There's a lot of things in your life that
can change by going here. I said, yeah,
but you know, I'm getting recruited by
some of these Ivy League schools to,
he says, Eh, it's not the same and I don't
think you're going to fit in. I honest,
I'm going to be honest with you,
Brian, my track coach, so bright guy.
So two days later I go to the naval
academy and a hand them my tape. Now.
They hadn't even started
recruiting me yet,
but those coaches were so nice to my
mom. And by doing that, it was mom,
they recruited my mom. They were so
respectful to her. The water was there.
It was so pretty. Okay.
You know, I'm, I'm in.
And I had made that decision early
that that's where I wanted to go and,
and focused on and that,
you know,
did some summer school to take some
classes to boost my AP courses in high
school just to make sure they don't
have to go to the prep school first.
I want to go right to the naval
academy. And so that, that in,
in a really quick nutshell,
football was a vehicle. Um,
along with my academics were good,
but you know, having a three,
five GPA and a 12,
10,
and your sats isn't normally going
to get you into the naval academy.
Football was,
was the vehicle that got me there.
And I could remember prom night lifting
weights in the weight room with my
rented Tux in the locker. I was there
all by myself. I had the security code,
I was, I, you know, one of the only
guys who worked all summer long.
I was the only white guy where I worked
in this tomato plant and I would work to
help pay for the high school I went to.
Cause my mom,
my mom took me out of public schooling,
put me in this good high school because
I got suspended a couple of times in
middle school and it was one of the
harder decisions but one of the best
decisions that she made
and pushed me towards,
cause the teachers at that school when
they saw me having this opportunity,
they helped, hey, let's help
Brian get to the Naval Academy,
go there to play football. But you know,
really get himself on a great trajectory.
And uh, there, there's
not a day I regret it.
There were definitely days I couldn't
stand being at the Naval Academy like
anybody hated it.
But the friends I made there,
the opportunities and the pathway to
the Marine Corps, still to this day,
I don't know if I'll ever be as good at
any job because I wasn't being a marine
infantry officer. I just,
I don't know that. And we,
when you got there you're,
they,
the type of football that they were
playing didn't really match your cause you
were a quarterback and I was right. And
so in the book you're saying that your,
your type of football didn't really
match what they wanted to do? No,
it was a rude awakening for me. You
know, I went there thinking, Hey,
I'm going to be the next Roger Staubach
and we all did and then all of a sudden
you start to see all these other
kids from all over the country. Wow.
They're good too.
I'd never really run the option before.
And they've got guys from the prep school
that already done a year in the system
and did that system in high
school that can run the option.
So next thing you know,
I'm getting moved to wider
Seaver and get moved to safety.
Then I'm getting moved,
a linebacker and I have to figure
out how to play these positions.
And it was one of the best lessons I ever
learned as a young man where I had to
make a decision,
I'm going to contribute to this team.
I'm not going to be a starter,
I'm not going to be a star.
Some of the best contributions I can
make as a leader are to help mentally
prepare the younger guys to play.
So my senior year,
I was competing for the starting outside
linebacker position and we had this
young kid named Bobby Mclaren who
was an animal, I mean an animal,
but he was uncontrollable. He could
not understand the defense at all.
He's still wild man, flying around,
knocking over anything he touched,
but he was an idiot if football was an
engineering major, really bright kid,
but a more on in football.
All right, so I'm a senior,
I'm going to help this kid out and
we're in two and I'm competing for the
starting job and I'm helping this kid
out who's third string and he's getting
frustrated and then all of a sudden he
starts to get it and he's starting to
grasp on.
And slowly but surely I could see this
kid taken not only my job but the job of
the guy who was ahead of me, who I
was competing with. And you know,
the bottom line was is I had to find
a way to contribute value to the team,
obviously has a special teams contributor,
but leadership was going to be the
biggest thing I contributed and,
and that made me a very valuable
member of the team that season.
And it taught me great lessons moving
forward both in the marine corps and
especially now in my job.
If you aren't finding a way to
add value to your organization,
to your team every day
and you're wasting time,
you're wasting money and
somebody's going to take that spot,
somebody will come along and take that
spot. I don't care how successful you get,
you can't take life for granted everyday.
You got to add value.
I learned that lesson
early in my football coach.
My linebacker coach liked me the most.
I was his favorite guy and he would admit
that to me in our personal meetings.
But the end of the day he
told me, Brian, I get paid.
I feed my family to put the best players
on the field who are gonna help us win
games. I really wished that was
you right now. But it's not.
And those are hard
conversations to listen to.
But if you're going to be a leader,
you gotta be able to receive that
information and find a way to get better.
Yeah. You know, speaking of that, so
you, you actually, they fired the coach
that you had your first three years.
New Coach came in and I'm going to go
to the book here. It's your senior year.
Two a days are brutal or deals detested
by every player who has stepped foot on
a, on a football field. That summer,
our new coach, Paul Johnson used
to a days to make a statement.
He made us proud and start
practicing before dawn.
Every day at zero four 45 we reported
to the field and Johnson's new coaching
staff beat us half to death with
repeated fourth quarter drills we ran.
We hit none of this.
No contact drilling.
Johnson spared no one by mid morning.
Guys were puking where they stood.
I love this right here.
No wonder why you pussies went oh and 11
he shouted more than once as we gasped
and suffered. Coach Johnson showed
no mercy when he evaluated the team,
he concluded that we lacked
discipline and motivation.
He made our two weeks in August,
a crucible designed to test our
toughness and our commitment to the team.
At one point, a wide receiver
went down with a phantom injury.
After the team doctor examined the
whiteout and found nothing wrong with him.
Coach Johnson demoted him on this bought.
So coach Johnson came in
and dropped the he have it.
I still remember, you know,
back then at the naval can,
we had what was called instant messenger.
And so you could leave in a way message,
you know, and your instant messenger.
And we did our fourth quarter drilled.
I remember our starting defensive end,
Pete Butte Miller, he left
in his away message. He said,
today I met death and death kicked my,
you know what?
It was brutal and they scream that
at us repeatedly. No wonder you went,
Oh and 11 we were in Naval
Academy football team and
the previous coach had let
discipline just run awry. You know,
both on the field in practice,
in the weight room, in films you could be
hurt all week, still start in the game.
The things that are essential for a
military academy team to win. I mean you,
you've gotta be in better shape than
the other team and you've got to commit
less mental errors because physically
you're never really going to match up.
Right? And we were making that
error and from all that chaos,
one of the,
the real amazing things I learned from
those coaches who that staff is basically
still there today.
Coach Niumatalolo was the offensive
coordinator when Johnson left.
He's now the head coach,
but they taught me as,
as leaders to expect excellent.
Every single drill,
every film session,
every weight room session,
every conditioning there was a standard.
You either meet the standard
or you don't meet the standard.
And if you don't meet the standard, there
are consequences. There's remediation.
There's ways that you have to fix it
because this is the only thing that's good
enough. If we're going to move
forward, you either get better,
you get worse every day. Getting
worse is unacceptable. And when,
when you take that mentality as an officer
to what you're doing in the field to
train 160 marines to go to combat,
all of a sudden that gets a lot more
serious than win and lose and football
games. But that, that, that holds true
in business. It holds true in anything.
There is a standard. And if you, if you
accept below that standard, just once,
that sets a precedent that could lead to
what happened before he got there. And,
and I've,
I've gone back to the Naval Academy
repeatedly and I've talked to the team.
I actually talked to the
junior class every single year.
And one of the things I always
tell those coaches, uh, gentlemen,
you guys are putting out a better
product as officers because you're here.
Your job is to put forth
the great football team.
But I promise you and the staff at
the Naval Academy, the officers,
they see it too.
They are making better leaders because
of what they're doing on the football
field before they got there,
that wasn't happening.
What was happening on the football field
is making, making us worse officers.
And so I, I still hold true, he
now coaches John Paul Johnson,
coaches at Georgia tech now,
he brought me down to speak to the team
a couple of years ago and we had some
great conversations,
but I mean he's still,
he's still that same guy still
thinks he can beat me up. Coach,
I get it. And I'm not asking you in
front of your teammates, you always say,
you can walk me. You have to realize now
there's not a chance, but he is not. Boy,
I'm telling you, I still think I
won't be and he'll throw this off.
You know right across.
It's geriatric at this point.
He could barely even get his arm up,
but he's still throws it like he can beat
me. He's game, he's gay, he's gained,
he's game. The heart's
there. The body though.
So you actually, you actually talk
about this in the book. So here we go.
All that effort, pain and misery made
me a more disciplined human being.
It prepared me for the trials ahead.
As a Marine infantry officer.
In fact,
many of the lessons I learned helped me
better prepare my platoon and later my
company for combat in Iraq,
in football and in a rifle company,
there is no substitute for discipline,
hard work and commitment.
If any of these elements are lacking,
the team is going to lose.
The company will get shot to
pieces and combat and men will die.
I learned there is no margin for error
in both and the only way to be perfect is
to demand perfection and
never Brooke excuses.
There you go.
That's life. I mean, you know at
that point especially then that is,
that is your world. That
is your life, the military.
So unique in that other jobs you can
leave at 5:00 PM 6:00 PM whenever you go
home from work. Hey, I am no longer
an accountant. Now I'm Jimmy, now,
I'm Sarah, now I'm, I'm whomever.
Right? But in the military,
if you're bad at your job,
you're a bad person.
And that's kind of how you're looking
at know if, you know, it's, it's true.
If you, if you're an infantry officer
and you're not good if you're in,
if this isn't everything you eat, sleep
and breathe your week. I mean that's just,
that's just the kind of
environment we have. And,
and I always tell the story when
people look at me like crazy.
I tell him this story had a marine
named James Brown, no affiliation with,
with the famous person. And, and James is
a great marine. He was a tough, tough kid.
And he was in a machine gun posts,
uh,
watching over a main avenue of approach.
And his job was to make sure that it
stayed clear. He had the best topics,
keep it clear of ids,
make sure nobody plants an IED there.
And everything was bulletproof around
him except for the one slit where the two
40 golf went through and
it was hot 125 degrees.
And, and people always ask me,
why are the Marines so extreme?
When you make statements like that,
discipline, commitment there, everything,
everything has to be perfect. I
tell them the story. It got hot.
James leaned against the rifle to get a
little breeze through that slip and that
moment got shot in the
head by a sniper and died.
It was an amazing shot when we
went up there and looked at where,
I mean in Iraq they had some very,
very good snipers as we know,
right?
But not one split moment.
I lost that marine and everything.
We do everything you do to perfection.
That's why you demand
perfection in everything you
do because you are so afraid
that they're not going to come home alive.
And I had to tell my
marines just one time,
they were lacking in some of
their standards. This is in Iraq.
I made them stand uniform inspections.
Imagine their attitude is,
I made them stand three uniform
inspection today and they were so mad.
But in leadership,
you can't do something like that without
telling them to why they're not going
to buy it. They're just going to hate you
now. And I told him, I said, listen guys,
we're not stranded.
We're not strapping down our
ammo and the Humvees well enough.
We're not cleaning our
weapons right after mission.
Like we should be not
wearing our uniforms.
We get back to camp because you think
you're so cool cause you've been in a
bunch of firefights.
If we don't do the little things right,
it's going to affect the big things.
And ultimately what's going to
happen is we are going to die,
we're going to lose or the people
we're here to protect are going to die.
Therefore I'm going to do these uniform
inspections until all of these things
are fixed permanently and I am totally
fine with you hating me right now.
If that means I will deliver you home
alive with the mission accomplished,
I'd rather you be alive and hate me.
Then you guys love me cause you think
I'm super cool but then have you guys die
because of my poor leadership and my
inability to keep you guys discipline and
keep you to the standard of perfection
and, and that is something, it's hard for.
People haven't been in that circumstance.
It's hard for them to understand.
It really is. But even in my
current job running a nonprofit, I,
I tell my staff, every single veteran
they speak to every conversation,
whether it's the 10 times you talked
to that vet and you're doing another
practice interview,
our job is to help them
find the American dream,
to leave the military by their own
choosing and now find not a job,
but a great career where they can thrive.
And if we take any conversation
with them for granted,
they may no longer want to take our
advice. They may go at it alone,
they may not the right
thing and we failed them.
People give us money not to fail them.
Your paid with other people's money
that they gave us to help these vets get
jobs. Period. If we're not doing that,
then you don't work here anymore.
I don't work here anymore, period.
We will find somebody else to
do it because that's our job.
And so you've got to set that standard.
But if you don't tell them the why
behind it, they'll never understand that.
And it doesn't mean that we have this,
this culture is not like my platoon
had this culture where we were all so
hardcore and there was no compassion,
there was no personality.
There's no smiles as
you can attest to look,
you can have an environment of discipline,
hard work and commitment,
but still have a lot of love,
compassion in good times.
You had fun, a lot of
straight up. You know,
it's great fun when you go and
you train and you're awesome.
You don't have a lot of fun.
The New England patriots,
they have a hell of a lot of fun and you
went to a discipline and commitment and
hard work.
That's why they're on the top and they
have a lot of fun smile at the end of
every season. Everybody hates on them
and they're raising the trophies. So
you got this section in the book that
talks about what you're talking about
right now, the leadership factory, right?
So here I'm going to go to the book.
All the academic classes in the world
will never teach anyone to be a leader.
The academy recognized that long ago
and while we had to take courses on the
subject, we learned by doing the academy
is structured to provide leadership
opportunities in a wide variety of places
and levels from the very first day you
start as plebes,
and this is emphasizing what you just
said and discipline is something that I
talk about all the time and,
and you know,
it's great as you know,
as I was talking to you on the way over
here, you know, I do, I do all of these,
I read these leadership
or not leadership books,
they're not books about leadership.
There are about combat, right?
But combat is about leadership.
So all these books, all of them,
every single one of them,
whether it's an ancient Roman military
leader or a marine in Vietnam or an army
soldier in World War II, they all, there
is one common thing that's disciplined,
disciplined, discipline. It's
always there. Back to the book,
discipline forms the cornerstone of any
military team and of course punishment
serves as one of the means
to maintain discipline.
During my junior year, I learned not
to be afraid to mete out punishment.
At the same time.
Doing so requires a balance of
appropriateness and understanding,
so that's the why you just
talked about right there,
and this again goes to something
that I talk about a lot, which is,
which is the dichotomy of leadership,
which is in leadership. There's,
there's opposing forces that are pulling
you into different directions and both
of them are right.
They're both right.
It's right to be hard on your guys and
maintain discipline and it's right to
love you guys and take care of her.
You have to balance those two and that's
what you're talking about right there.
That's what you were
talking about when you were,
when you were talking about they need to
understand why they're being punishment,
punished back to the book.
Bad officers try to be
buddies with their marines.
There's a fine line between getting to
know you're getting to know the men under
your command and bonding
with them as friends.
It is all too easy to make that mistake
at the same time. Here's the balance.
At the same time,
if a young second lieutenant doesn't
make an effort to know his men,
his aloofness becomes a drag and will
hinder his ability to command in several
ways. First, you won't understand the
strengths and weaknesses of his squads.
More important,
he won't have the respect or the
connection needed to motivate and lead.
In the worst of circumstances,
men will follow other men into the worst
possible circumstances if they respect
and believe in their leadership
like all other aspects of command.
It is a delicate balance.
Okay,
so you're, you're just everything you
just said. You say it in the book and
okay,
that's why you're talking about the
leadership factory, but it's interesting.
This is stuff that I'm sure they
touched on it in the classes,
but that's the stuff that you learn.
You learn it from senior enlisted people,
you learn it from other officers,
you learn it yourself,
you work for people and you
go, man, this guy's aloof.
This guy's not talking to us. So it's
stuff that we learned ourselves too.
I'm going to finish this section up.
I concluded the proper
balance here depended on the
officer's ability to listen
and accept input while still making it
clear that he was the ultimate decision
maker.
That was the key.
A second lieutenant couldn't be afraid
to engage in frank and productive
dialogue with his key leaders.
A platoon becomes the reflection of
its commander. He sets the example,
and this is from what you just said,
if his uniform is jacked up,
his men won't care about their own.
This leads to disciplinary issues
and becomes a very slippery slope.
The only way a second lieutenant can
have the moral authority to set a high
standard is to set a high standard for
conditioning and appearance is to Stevie
example himself.
Okay.
Without conditioning, opportune cannot
achieve its potential in the field.
Aggressiveness suffers.
Okay.
Appearance breeds pride and reinforces
discipline and a spree decor.
So those,
that's the leadership factory that you're
talking about and clearly those things
that you brought from the football
field and from the academy,
you apply them right directly into
your folks in combat. They helped and,
and you know the Marine Corps has a
really unique circumstance where they have
the basic score.
Every single officer goes there and
that's huge to set this huge standard.
Then we go a step further where when
we go to infantry officer course,
that course was 13 weeks long. One of
the very hardest, if not the hardest,
the Marine Corps,
mentally, physically, everything. You
don't know anything that's coming,
everything's a surprise.
But I felt that my instructors during
our course were phenomenal and they were
getting all the real time
intelligence from the battlefield.
All the training was realistic.
But in terms of how you relate to your
marines from your junior enlisted to
your, your middle rank,
to your senior enlisted,
how you relate to the senior enlisted
from the battalion who worked directly for
the battalion staff.
How you manage those
relationships to maximize the
effectiveness of your platoon,
to make sure that you can
get exactly what they need.
They did such a good job of that.
Then you take it one step further.
When I reported third battalion,
Second Marines,
I'd be remiss if I didn't give credit
to a guy by the name of Gabe Diana,
who is a lieutenant colonel in
the Marine Corps now I believe,
but he taught me he was a true student
of leadership and military history.
He would tell me all the time,
his craft is his hobby.
There's nothing else he cared about. It's
what he was. He loved being a marine,
love being an officer,
and he taught me a lot about
decentralized leadership,
how to not micromanage,
how to empower your junior leaders,
that they start to think like you and you
could achieve tempo on the battlefield
and you could immediately see
examples of marines. I call it,
and I see it all the time in the
business world. I call it JV leadership,
where I'm a great leader if my people
love me and they're the same leaders that
will tell their people,
our it guys today,
we've got to stay 30 minutes longer
because headquarters said so, look,
I disagree with it. I think it's
ridiculous, but we have to do it,
so let's just sit here together.
Now none of their people are
actually going to work motivated.
There'd be no discipline.
There's going to be no standard that
they're trying to achieve because of that
horrible leadership JV or angry at
headquarters. Absolute, they're there.
They're Batman at the chain of command.
Exactly as JV leadership,
and I'm constantly trying to talk to
people about that. A JV leadership.
The first thing of it is you think you
have to be loved to be an effective
leader. If you are an effective leader
over the long term, you will be loved.
But there's going to be intermittent
parked where they can't stand you.
They don't understand things all the
time or they're gonna be mad at you and
their cause it.
Cause there are emotional but over long
term they're gonna understand that what
you did was best. The other, the second
major part to JV leadership is thinking,
Hey,
I'm in charge,
therefore I come up with all the great
ideas and I'm going to make every single
decision without your input and I'm gonna,
I'm gonna really try hard to make
sure that he knows I am in charge.
That's ridiculous. It is not your job
to come up with all the great ideas.
Some of the best ideas I
received were from 19 year olds,
21 year olds who had already been direct
ones, had a grace or I got a great idea.
Well, I want to hear all about it's, it's,
it's our job as leaders to decide which
are the best ideas to invest energy,
time, and resources in. And that's not
just, I get all this stuff all the time.
When I talked to different
groups and companies, well,
military leadership is different
than corporate leadership. Why?
What am I saying here that does doesn't
apply. Well, it, it's too extreme.
It is not, you're taking us
too literal with, with, with,
with our warrior mentalities
here, you know, the,
that you do not need to be an insecure.
The best leaders are not insecure.
They're secure.
They know that they're there and
ultimately gonna make the final decision.
But it empowers your people and
you could achieve tempo when you're
decentralized enough that they feel
good about coming up with ideas,
sending them up to you to get back up
for it and get resources behind it.
But also knowing that they can make the
appropriate decisions at their level
because they know what your final intent
is. Here's the outcome I want achieved.
You get us there. You're the expert
at it. That's why I hire Jim.
I didn't tell my machine gunners how
to work their t and e system and how to
cite in their machine guns.
Right.
I just told him what I wanted them
to hit their better than that.
It me taking the time to spend it with
my marines in their different functions
and aspects and talk to
them about how they're,
they're the expert and compliment them
like that. It made them feel great.
It does wonders for a
leader to go to their level,
see what they do every day and see that
expert work cause they don't expect you
to be an expert in all of that. They
know that, right. Your job is different,
your responsibilities are different. You,
you need to have greater perspective.
But when you go to their level in respect,
what they do and show them respect
for what they do and how they do it,
man,
it's a powerful thing that that could,
that could make a group of people so
much better collectively than they ever
would have been individually. And when
it happens, right, when it finally,
when you finally get there and can
achieve that, it is, it is awesome.
It's the most rewarding
experience you could ever have.
And it's hard for people to, to understand
because most people, they, well,
the most rewarding experience you guys
probably have is killing people. No,
it's so much different than that.
So much different.
There's so much more to
it than that. Yeah. Yeah.
It's interesting too that by the way,
what you're saying right now is basically
the entire book that my buddy Leif
Babin,
this is the mood.
There's a chapter in there
called decentralized command
with everything you're
saying. So, but, and that's why you know,
you've come up in a completely different,
you know, in the Marine Corps.
I was in the, in the, in
the navy and yet, you know,
you and I have both.
I can tell right now basically
completely aligned leadership principles.
Isn't it interesting though that some
guys don't get it if he don't get it and
you could explain it to them
and you'd say, listen man, hey,
you don't need to make every decision.
And in fact,
when you get out in a firefight,
you won't be able to make every decision.
You're going to have to let your leaders
lead and you're going to let have to
let and the,
and they would listen to you and you could
see it going right through their head.
It's wild.
You wonder what psycho psychological he
is going on in there that makes you want
to rebel. And a lot of times it's, hey,
they got a bad review from officer said,
this is their way of saying, you know,
hey, uh, you know, go fly a kite. You
know this, this is their way of rebelling.
I noticed that with some officers. Um,
and in some of the, you know, I had,
I had a fire lieutenant during my second
deployment and, and he had this problem,
you know, he kept feeling he had to
be best friends with his marines.
He spent way too much time with them
talking about a lot of personal stuff.
They'd be out on patrol and
nobody would listen to them.
I mean it was almost straight Muni.
And then when I had to fire him and here
was the thing is, and tell them, look,
you're a really good person and you are
most likely going to be very successful
in whatever you choose to do.
So please, please remember that.
It's hard to hear that now this is a
very unique job and we are in a very
dangerous dinner and we were already in
Iraq and we were in a dangerous area at
the time and things were about to go
south and I had to remove this kid now
before things got worse.
And it was hard for him to understand
that you can be a phenomenal human being,
a great person,
but just not meant to lead,
especially in in those circumstances.
But it's,
it's some people,
and I think it obviously,
if they have so many years growing up
in a household where it was so different
from what they're being taught,
that I think sometimes is the route for
them to push back against this type of
leadership. No. You know, I've been
taught differently for years and years.
It's Kinda like, well how did you just
block it all out for the, you know,
year and a half you've been in school
before you got here with guys with all
this combat experience and not to mention
the hundreds of years of history of
combat experience saying, look,
this is the best way to do it. Yes.
And saying, no, I'm going to
do a different thing. I mean,
the military is a business.
It is a business.
It's run like a business
and the leadership there,
it's about maximizing the potential of
all the human beings that you have on
your team. And how do you do that? Yes,
it involves tactics and in what we do is
different, but the, the, the personal,
the small unit down to the large
unit leadership is all the same.
It's all the same.
And you go around and you
talk to different executives
who are having trouble.
Well, you know this, you know,
it's the millennials and what they
do and what they do in this do,
and we were talking about
in the right here, people,
the experts always want to
blame some kind of process.
I think you're processing your
information flow is wrong.
And the way that you have your workflow
set up in the office space that's
causing this issue in
communication. No, it's not.
You're saying that because you are afraid
to have the hard conversations with
the leaders who are failing, which by
the way, you're one of the leaders. Yes.
So when you're failing as a business
and you've got these issues, yeah,
it's breathe,
you're going to be one of the problems
and you might need help squaring that
away. And that's okay. That's
okay. I'll do you know what?
Another thing I noticed in business
world is a lot of people in the business
world, they have no leadership
training. So they've figured it out,
they've been lucky and successful and
they've gotten by with good and then they
get to a certain point where all of a
sudden they're going, wait a second,
I can't handle this anymore.
That you know,
if you grow from six people that you know
pretty well that you trust and all of
a sudden you've got a
staff of a hundred people.
If you don't start learning how to lead,
you're going to have significant
problems and it's going to blow up.
And that happens from a hundred
people to 300 people in it,
from 300 people to a thousand people.
It'll happen every time.
And you've got to train those leaders
throughout the chain of command that all
have the same understanding
of the fundamental principles
of combat leadership,
which is leadership.
You have the thrill combat in there.
Cause that was my old job. It's funny
you bring it up. There's a great example.
Dan Quinn is the current head coach.
At the Atlanta Falcons.
He was a defense coordinator at Seattle,
hires the head coach in
Atlanta and through his,
he's a very good friend of Jake Lazar
who's obviously very involved in mixed
martial arts and does a lot of the Fox
broadcast and I've worked with him and
gotten close with them and
so Jay introduced me to Dan.
Dan was looking to make the team tougher
in and here's a guy who has achieved
the highest level of leadership and
coaching, just like you talked about.
He was a great coordinator.
Now he's a head coach and he had the
humility to seek out experts from all,
I mean he went to different sports,
talk to their head coaches,
he went to the military,
he went all over with humility to ask
and get advice and glean experience other
people's time and leadership to include,
I couldn't believe it,
but here I am having
breakfast at demand here.
I'm in his office or I'm in there and,
and you know their little cafeteria.
There were just talking leadership
and he's talking about some of these
individual guys and he's
actually listening to my opinion.
Wanted to hear what I went through,
my opinion on this guy or that guy is,
he brought me in to do some martial
arts drills to make the team tougher,
but I gained so much respect for that.
Here's a man who's achieved the
highest level. He knows he's in charge,
he's not out to prove anything.
His guys know he's in charge and when
they don't meet the standard there's a
consequence.
But at the same time he shows them the
same kind of humility as he seeks out
advice to get better every day because
he wants them. Hey Julio Jones,
I know you think you're the
best wide receiver in football,
but there's ways you can get better and
you need to be humble enough to find
them. And guess what? Julio goes
first in every drill. The dudes that,
I mean he at that,
I've watched him work as hard as any human
being I've seen in the football field,
always looking to get better.
Matt Ryan the same and look at
the position of the teams and now,
but he has continually done that.
He turned to navy seals last summer,
brought seals and to work with his
team to work with him on leadership,
on accountability and all this combat
but leadership leaders and bring it into
that locker room and create this
cohesive unit that has had a tremendous
turnaround from the 2015
season to now 2016 yeah. Yeah.
Now to championship again
for you reciting my book,
which is what to do, cause we were in a
chapter there, it's called check your ego.
And you know,
my point is the number one,
the number one characteristic that
a leader has to have his humility.
And if you don't have that, all those
things that you just talked about,
you won't do any of them.
You won't ever get better.
You won't listen to anybody else.
You won't take any advice. You can't.
That's a horrible thing. Um, let me,
let me, let me get us back on track
to your life a little bit here.
Uh, why did you pick the Marine
Corps? Because I couldn't swim
in all honesty.
You know,
I had thought for a while that I wanted
to be a team guy playing football and
trying to be a cla. It's
extremely competitive. You know,
the guys who went into the teams and
I mean physical specimens discipline,
they're incredible.
They train for four years to then go and
and do all these different screeners.
Uh, and for me not having spent four years
in the pool was costly because when it
came time for me to do this
screen or to go do mini buds,
it was basically a mini hell week
for four straight days. The academy,
it was tough and we broke the ice and
the Chesapeake, all of that, you know,
I trained for it for two weeks.
Right.
I still had a shoulder problem in
hamstring prompt and the season,
I mean it was just not going to, I was
not going to compete with these guys for,
um, but ultimately what attracted
me was the Warner racket started.
Lot of my buddies were, were in the march
up that I had played with that were,
you know,
graduated before me.
I had talked to some folks that were in
special operations and seals and they
talked about it and it's a smaller team,
so it's a little bit different.
Whereas in the Marine Corps, the
leadership, you know, very young age,
you're going to have 40 some marines.
You'll go on to be a company
commander at this level,
you're going to get a
legitimate opportunity to
command large scale units. And,
and that was really
appealing to me. Um, and,
and I thought that that was probably
the best opportunity for me because if I
was going to try to then be a team guy,
I was going to have to go into the
navy as a surface warfare officer.
And then after two years and then after
two years as rough try to get to butts
and there's no guarantees. Being a
seal is extraordinarily competitive.
And the physical requirements as
officers to to get there are really,
really high. And so for me, the,
the Marine Corps had an amazing appeal
and which we know about the Marine Corps.
When you went to the Naval
Academy though? I wasn't. I,
I did as soon as I went to plebe
summer. Cause they run it, they run it.
And I'll tell you a lot of the, a lot
of the people at the naval, Kevin,
when I was there, hated
the marines. Really.
So many of them went there with
a chip on their shoulder. You,
this is the naval academy.
There's no marine corps stuff and
it's when we get our opportunity,
we're really going to be jerks.
And we had this great lieutenant colonel
when I was a senior and we had all been
selected to be Marines who told us, look
guys, this is not the real Marine Corp.
They're not representing as well. We've
got a bad crop here right now that are,
that are trying to prove a point.
When you get to the basic school,
you're gonna find that it's
massively different. And I loved,
I loved everything about it.
I loved the diversity of my marines.
I mean we talk about race and race
is a big deal. Racism in our country,
it's a big topic. I mean there's
constantly battles on all the,
the Hollywood news sites
going on about about race
didn't exist when I was
in the Marine Corps.
Men from all over the world, dark
green marine. It didn't matter. It did.
It did not matter if we
didn't care. Everybody, Hey,
this is so and so the salt.
We didn't care. We had a mission
every day. We trained together,
we bled together and it was phenomenal.
None of that stuff existed
because we won together.
We suffer together and
we look beyond all of it.
It just doesn't matter in the military
and it's so frustrating to see it.
It matters so much here in the regular
world where people have all kinds of
preconceived things and some people are
out there acting like they're fighting
on for the,
for the better of of race relations in
our country and they're making it worse
because they've got their own
personal agenda as they do it.
It's just really frustrating.
Yeah. Well, I definitely in the,
in the military, like you said,
everyone's wearing the
same uniform and the,
I'm sure in the fifties and
sixties and even into the 70s,
it was a big deal and they stamped it
out because it, it, it doesn't matter.
There's no factor one way or the other.
It's no factor that it's pretty awesome.
Uh, yeah, went to the
basic school. You, uh,
you got stalled in the basic school
for a little bit of time and you know,
going through some legal stuff and while
you're stalled at the basic school,
your friends start going on deployment and
all of a sudden you got your
classmates, your friends, your brothers
are getting killed and you know,
that feeling of being on the sidelines.
Um,
I think it's really hard to
explain to people and you,
and you do a good job in the book that
I'll, I'll highlight a couple of times,
but, uh, I heard this quote
one time, man, I'm not,
I'm going to throw it out
there as best I can. But for,
for women,
like they have an intrinsic
biological desire to have children.
Not all women,
but a lot of women let's say,
and a lot of men
have an intrinsic desire to go to war.
I don't know why that is.
I know I had it since I can
remember having human emotions.
I wanted to go to war, you know
what I mean? When you're a kid,
the first thing you do when you pick up
a stick is you shape it into a gun and
start pointing it at your friends
and trying to kill them. Right.
So here you were on the
sidelines sitting back and,
and your friends are starting
to get killed. Well how,
what did that do to your psychology?
It was,
it was dark.
It was psychologically,
that was the most challenging
time period of my life.
You've got someone challenging
your character and your
honor trying to say that
you, that you were something
that you weren't and I
wouldn't allow it. They were,
there were easier ways to speed up
the process and I refused. No Way.
I know what happened. And, and
during that delay it was a very,
very dark period and,
and it was difficult,
but you have to,
you have to slow life down some times,
gain perspective and realize, hey
look, this is going to take some time.
Eventually I am going to get there.
But what,
what really it turned into when the
opportunity finally came to progress using
my time wisely. The war wasn't
going to go away tomorrow. You know,
sometimes you get this feeling
in your mind like, Oh man,
my friends are out there dying.
They're leading.
I need to be with them
right now realizing wall,
it's not going to be gone tomorrow.
So don't be so anxious.
Don't waste the time you have
now to get better. What can I do?
I'm not going to let this stupid instance
hold me back from improving from when
I eventually do go on to lead marines.
And so I found a way to contribute value.
I found a way to get better. It
didn't happen right away. You know,
there was a couple of weeks
where where it was dark,
where I was angry but I snapped out of
it because there's times in life where
life and your psychology,
they want it.
You want to be the victim,
right?
You want to feel like you've been wronged
and the problem is is a lot of times
when you go into that mode and
you start playing the victim,
you never crawl out of it.
You get stuck in that world of the victim.
You get stuck in this world that you
think is all bad lock and everything's
always going against you
and you stop driving.
You know your own life. You got to crawl
out of that. When, when, when your,
when your mind is telling you to play
the victim and to feel bad for yourself,
nothing positive comes from that.
Some nothing.
Did something specific snap you
out of that mindset that your,
your mom tell you something or you
must read it. They talk about that.
Oh that's right. That's right.
Yeah, she did. Is she my, my,
my mom is the sweetest
woman in the world too.
But there are specific time in my life
where she was extremely hard on me and
they've mama stay where they were
at the right times. You would,
you'd meet her knight in a quick
kind of, she's such a pushover. Um,
but there were times where,
hey, you're going to fight this.
You understand me, you're
gonna fight this. You're right.
That's it. And you move
forward and, and you, oh,
just like we owe the,
the friends that you lose,
there are many different ways
that we could remember them,
that we can memorialize them. Some people
choose the wrong way, in my opinion,
substance, alcohol,
depression. You know, they,
they choose more of a victim
mindset way of remembering them.
Others choose, hey, there are no
longer here. I can't bring them back.
What would they want me to be doing?
What would make them proud?
I take their life for granted if I use
them as an excuse to be idle and fail.
Right? But I'm a more,
and if I remember them,
speak their name and talk about
them as I move on and I succeed and,
and I still think about that.
I think about Ronnie Winchester who I
played football with who died now came
from Iraq.
I think about Brett Harmon who was
killed at an NC state football tailgater
before he could even lead
his platoon to battle.
And those incidents happen again
while you're on the sidelines.
And the other thing you started doing
right now at that time period is what does
that saying when the, when the student is
ready and instructor will appear? Well,
you ended up at the Marine Corps,
the Martial Arts Center for excellence
and you started training. I did.
I ran into to a colonel
named Joe [inaudible],
who is just this phenomenal guy,
all about character.
I mean in his sixties could outrun all
of us. I mean the epitome of discipline,
discipline, discipline.
And he brought me in.
I started working there and I got further
introduced into martial arts and I
loved it. I found, hey,
this is what I should be doing in my
free time. I should be in heavy bags.
I should be trained and I should be
watching tape. I need to beat we.
If I'm not reading military history
and learning about my enemy,
I'm doing this stuff,
this,
this is the type of stuff that's
going to keep my mind sharp.
And then I got intrigued. I wondered,
okay, I'm going to lead marines in combat.
And a lot of these books that they were
making us read on killing and some of
these books that, that in my opinion
are a little off on the psychology,
the psychology of battle.
Agree. I mean, just brutal guy.
You're gonna pee yourself before
he gets shot at actually negative.
I'm not going to be myself,
so I wondered. All right, well what
can get me ready for that anxiety?
Sign up for a fight.
I had this master gunnery sergeant who
was a really good kickboxer who worked at
this martial arts center of exos
and a master, a master guns.
Will you train me for fight?
Can you get me like one of these,
these martial arts fights out in
town? Yes sir. I can get you one.
Are you going to show up? Yeah, of course.
I'm going to show up. I don't know. Sorry.
I get a lot of you officers that don't.
So anyways,
I convinced him to train me every morning
at five in the morning. We're training.
I had six weeks is fine. I don't
know much. Right. I've got,
I've got a black belt in the Marine
Corps martial arts program, right.
That's an arm bar from the guard and
armbars from the mount a suite and how to
escape them out and I don't, I've
never shrimped before. All right.
I don't know. A Butterfly Guard is, I
have no clue at half guard is all right.
I've got a jab cross and [inaudible]
ready for your first, the black belt,
you said that was a black clothes black.
I've got a Jab, a cross in the lake.
Understand. Let me just,
all right, so I get it.
It was my first amateur fight.
We weigh in and the guys older than me
and he's got the same haircut as Chuck
Ladell and he's pretty ripped and so
you'd weigh in the same day as the fight.
So we all leave now it's time
to eat and then you come back.
And so I come back and I'm,
I'm warm up and he hasn't shown up yet.
There's only a little sheet that they
hung off a bar in between us and our
fights come up in two fights. I'm
like, man, this guy may not show up.
So this is the perfect scenario for
me. He doesn't show, he was scared.
I go out with all my marine
buddies in the crowd or, I mean,
there's 50 people at despite and 15 and
we're there to watch me and that makes
it work, right? And so, uh,
he shows up and he's warming up.
He stretched and I'm like looking
through the sheet like, oh,
maybe I need to do some of that too, you
know, I don't want to tell them. Anyways,
we walked down this tarp,
the fight starts and this dude,
he hits me with the worst spinning
back fist you've ever seen. I mean,
slow motion off balance.
My head's so big.
Anything you throw at
it hits any damn way.
But it's me at the spinning back fist
and I'm starting to get embarrassed.
He's coming at me aggressive and and
now is that decision point. Okay,
I can mentally break now and kind of
cover up and get outta here if this is a
little uncomfortable for me.
And at that point I kind of snapped and
I got mad and so I go to try and take
them down, which I have no wrestling
football. He read, I tried to football,
he wraps up a guillotine on me full on,
wraps the legs around my waist
and he is hammered it everything.
He's got you here and it's tight.
I make a few of the lights going on.
I'm like, oh my goodness. No. And I
could hear his corner man yelling to him.
It's his wife.
It's now,
not only am I going to get
capped out in the first round,
I'm going to get tapped out to a fake
chocolate Lbu quarter by his wife,
finished in cherry phase two.
This does happen.
I find a way out of the choke.
I kicked him in the leg and realize
who I kick cardiac like that.
And then I'd crack him in the
forehead and I split his head open.
The doctor comes in, he doesn't know what
month it is and the fights over. And,
and I had, there was a bunch of Vietnam
vets in the crowd and they're hammered.
And as soon as I get out these
dudes, these guys, he's crusty,
fellas throw their arms are, I mean,
spilling beer all over me there.
They're feed me that,
you know,
they're putting the beer down
my throat from their cup with,
they got dips in there. I mean, this
stuff is probably disgusting. I hate,
but it takes it so good. And from
that moment on, I was hooked.
You know,
at this is this is what I should be doing.
I had six weeks of a fight on my
mind. If I can get used to that, how,
how will I deal with the anxiety
of, of unprepared for battle. Hey,
we're on patrol. You know, we get
contact. What's our media action?
Or we're going to have a major
operation coming up in six days.
I have to be able to think
clearly on the battlefield.
Direct lead play chess.
And so I thought, man,
this fighting thing could be a key.
It could be a help.
And it certainly did
not end up being that,
but it ended up being my
sanctuary through it all. It was,
it was kind of what centered me.
I brought typepad to Iraq the first time,
you know, I had one, oh one of my
sergeants, a pretty good martial arts.
We would train in between missions.
I would train my guys.
See that's the difference between the
seal teams and the and the Marine Corps.
You brought tie pads.
I brought maps
like I had Matt rooms. That's ridiculous.
The budget, the budget is much, much.
I know it seems like almost
embarrassing for me to admit. You know,
you also did a lot of
wrestling drills with uh,
with Travis Manion who was one of your,
one of your buddies.
And so he helped you out.
And there's a,
there's an interesting part in,
in the book where you talk about,
you and Travis are going to,
Brett, who you just talked about,
you're going to his funeral.
This is the guy was shot at some
little scuffle as he stayed.
Tailgater there's a real
shot in the chest and killed.
You guys are going to his funeral and
the wrestling coach tells you guys to
write your own eulogy for yourselves,
for yourselves. Interesting
drill. That's a,
that's an interesting drill.
Joel share it.
He is the head coach at the naval academy
wrestling team right now and it was
wild, you know, so Brett harm
was a marine infantry officer.
He was in third battalion, second marines,
which would be my eventual battalion.
Went to an NC state football tailgate or
there were some guys there drinking and
driving and they almost
hit a kid and so they,
him and his buddy from Chicago civilian
right out front of the car and stopped
him and they got an argument.
What are you guys doing?
You know you guys are drunk. Should
be driving. The guys get out.
They started to scuffle Breton.
His buddy one came back a couple hours
later and shot them both point blank,
shot breadth buddy in the face and Brett
went to get them to take the gun from,
he got shot in the chest and they died.
And so he was interesting because as
we were writing this eulogy, you know,
me and Travis,
we were so close and he was a,
he was a fantastic wrestler and one of
the toughest human beings I've ever known.
I mean what we used to do to each other
was ridiculous training. I mean if it,
as long as it was standing, I
would, I would just destroy them.
As soon as he got sick of that and
wanted to tackle me on the ground,
I wasn't getting up anymore
and he was destroying me.
But it would just go back and forth for
hours and instead of playing video games,
drinking beer,
going out and hitting on girls,
that's what me and Travis would
do on a Friday and Saturday night.
And it was really tough when
you really start to think,
what do you want to be said
when it's all over for you?
How do you want to be? Remember?
And, and I remember Travis,
he really struggled with this
struggled. I mean, it was, I mean,
he was so loud talking about that it
real from the plane. It was weird. And,
and part of it was because we were just
struggling with the fact that, you know,
our friend is dead, you know,
for such a weird circumstance.
Yet we can understand if it was an IED
or a snipe or something that and that,
not this. And, you know,
several years later it was
wild. But, uh, you know,
Joel share it when he would give Travis's
eulogy, he brought that story up.
Travis would get killed in Fallujah.
And I remember driving up to
Travis this funeral and Ah,
you know, Travis is one of those guys that
you just, you just never, he can't die.
He's Jesus. Too Bad. He's too
tough. He's too smart, too good.
So remember driving up to
the funeral and I had my,
my wife there with me and she was actually
trying to make plans for their twin
sister. Hey, we're going to be in
town. We live in North Carolina.
Let's get together this weekend.
But her twin sister's husband
didn't want to get together.
There was a part of me that
didn't Travis's in debt like,
I'm going to get there and we're all
gonna, we're gonna hang out tonight.
And I remember when I walked into that
week and I actually saw him, I mean it,
it hit me like a ton of
bricks. It was brutal. I loved,
love that guy so much and we carried
him the next day. But uh, you know,
it's just,
it's so crazy how connected it was because
Ronnie Winchester died in,
I'll Chi my rack and three days later,
Brett and died at that
NC state football game.
We would go to Brett Harmon's
funeral, right? Or on eulogies,
which you'll share it,
who would then end up giving Travis
Mannion his you has actually eulogy and I
would carry Travis to his grave.
I went to al Qaeda in Iraq and actually
replaced Ronnie's platoon and turned
over with the replacement
platoon commander who took
over for him when he passed.
While I was an infantry officer course
JP blacksmith was killed. And Felicia,
and I got this a little out of
order, but when, when JP died,
I found out right before I
had my last amateur fight,
I was an infantry officer course.
And I'm getting ready to
fight in two hours for,
for a title Travis Mannion
with my corner man.
And we're in the hotel room and he got
a call and then he looked like he had
seen a ghost like trap. What's
wrong? You have nothing to do.
I'll tell you after the fight. And we,
you know, we had gotten bad like, no,
I know something's up.
What the hell happened?
Travis told me do JP blacksmith
got killed in Fallujah.
So Travis tells you about jps death.
I turned over with jps
company, my second tour, it's,
I met all of his old marines, all of his
own platoon commanders. And it's just,
it's such a small world that we lived
and breathed then, you know, and,
and so in,
in my little platoon commanders notebook,
I had pictures of all of them.
And before every mission I would
flip through and you just think,
how do I make them proud?
Before every fight,
I would look at their pictures and
look at the pictures of my marines.
How do I make them proud?
And I still think about it to this day
and I end a lot of my speeches on this
and mean they no longer
have the chance to live.
Who am I to take this life for granted?
Because they would give
anything to have one more day.
Their families who would give
And I try to remind myself
of that all the time.
And you don't have to in the military to
think like that. People look into, well,
that's extreme. Well, who have you lost
in your life? What would make them proud?
How do you truly memorialize them?
It's certainly not through failure.
It's not they're being idle in life.
Live a life of substance,
not just existence in that you know,
as you do that and you remember them,
that makes them proud, that that makes
it, that makes it worth it. You know,
it's very similar to that,
that final scene in saving private
Ryan where he's like, did I earn it?
You know?
And for those of us who served and wearing
in those great circumstances or for
those people,
there's people that were in tragedies
where they were in car accidents.
They lost people.
They think the same way.
They think a lot the way they do that
we do when we look at life and taking
things for granted. Um, and
achieving every day adding value.
Yeah. The darkness in the world regardless
of, uh, regardless of where you are.
You, um, you know, speaking
of your combat tours, I want,
I want to kind of dive into those
a little bit and let's take you,
you take over your platoon.
You're a platoon commander. Now,
back to the book here,
during our first platoon meeting,
my introductory speech
lasted less than two minutes.
We're going to be aggressive.
I told my new command,
we're going to train our asses
off and we're going to be,
and we're going to work harder
than anyone else in the battalion.
That was it short to the point,
all business.
What's more, they found out
quickly. I wasn't kidding.
So you, you guys work
hard, you get prepared,
you deploy to Al came,
which you just talked about.
That's where you ended up going
and I'm jumping ahead a little bit.
People are going to have to read this
whole book themselves, but you're,
you're basically now setting
up a position on a bridge.
You're kind of a blocking force
in his bridge, prevent uh,
enemy from consolidating on another area
where there's another operation going
on and I'm going to the book mortars
began to fall on our position as we fought
back. I made sure that our vehicles
moved from one spot to another.
So the mortar Cruz would not zero in on
us from a wadi that ran perpendicular
route. Emerald, several
insurgents began lobbying,
rocket propelled grenades at us.
The rockets exploded all around us.
Then another heavy machine gun let loose
this one sided on the north bank as
well. We were caught in 180
degree crossfire from my window.
I could see Corporal
Delatour and Bravo one,
they were taking the brunt of the fire
and delatour briefly dipped out of the
Turret as bullets bounced
off the Humvees armored skin.
Then I saw his hand pop up above the
blast shield holding a video camera.
It takes a rare kind of cool to do
something like that in combat and infantry
platoons first task at to achieve
fire superiority over the enemy.
To do this requires pouring it on the
insurgence until they are forced to either
disengage or go to ground.
Once they're even driven off,
either driven off or pinned in place,
you've gained command to the fight and
can dictate what happens next even with
the tanks because I failed to mentioned
you had some tanks from army tanks with
you and you, uh,
throughout the book have the same deep
love for tanks that I have for RB tags,
Marie Techs, but I love tanks
even with the tanks. In this case,
we didn't have the fire power
to gain control of this battle.
There were too many insurgent shooting
at us from too many different places.
We needed some help.
I reached for the radios,
headset began calling air
strikes within minutes.
Huey Cobra gunships thundered in all
unseen to deliver deadly Accurate Hellfire
missiles into targets we identified.
So was this situation here,
was that like your first
big combat scenario?
It was,
it wasn't.
The thing that made it so difficult was
there was another platoon assigned for
that mission. Right. And they
got stuck, stuck in the mud,
in the mud and, and so we didn't get the
opportunity to aerial reconnaissance.
We didn't have the opportunity to look
at overhead imagery of this terrain.
We had nothing. I had 15 minutes, hey,
if they're not there in 15 minutes,
you're a go. So in that 15 minutes, I'm
briefing my guys, we're getting ready,
we're now, we're meeting this, this
tank crew is from Boise, Idaho.
We'd never even met them.
I met them the day before.
My guys had never worked with them before.
So there was a lot of confusion that
took place just in the, in the route up.
And as we got settled and started
identify targets, and as you know,
in that scenario,
the acoustics and in the movement,
the amount of people,
we are the most precise military
in the history of this planet.
So we not only have to identify
where is the gunfire coming from,
what caliber do I believe they're
firing back or at us with,
because that dictates what caliber
I'm allowed to return fire with.
Depending on where they're
shooting at me from.
Are they in a dug in position north of
the river or they shooting at me from a
building where they're civilians around?
Are they shooting at me from a wadi
where now I can drop hellfires on them.
I can hit them with tanks.
That's a lot going through your
head when you've got four vehicles,
two tanks and aircraft you're trying
to control as a 24 year old kid and
everybody's waiting on you to say what's
coming next. Just like in every vehicle,
there's another kid in there directing
everything they're doing and, and,
and that is, that is all part of
it. But that, that was our first,
our first time when Delatorre
I don't put in the book,
but what I said to him
over the radio, I mean, I,
I verbally almost killed him
through the radio for doing it,
that wild son of a bitch.
I've told him
the story on the podcast,
but I had a similar story.
I'll tell it again right now.
Cause Mikey Monster, who ended up
getting killed in Ramadi, metal of honor,
uh, I went to go to his little station
where he was and the guys were like, Hey,
do you see Mikey's video? And I
was like, no, let let you know.
And they'll go take a look at
Mikey's video. So Mikey was a, uh,
a heavy weapons gunner
and carry the mark 48.
And so I go back into his little
word Camp Corregidor in Ramadi.
I go back and do a little Hoochie,
a built from south. I'm like, Mikey,
let me see your, let me see your video.
And he goes, I'll Roger that sir.
So he pulls out a little camera and he
shows the video and there's a massive
firefight going on in the lob district of,
of Ramadi,
and he's got the camera up and you
can see it ducked out or go up.
He's filming everything and
he gets done showing me an,
and at one point and the in the video,
he turns the camera at himself
and he goes, it's the Mooloolaba,
which was just classic Mikey and this.
So it gets done.
And of course I'm all hardcore
and I go, hey Mike, bro,
what are you doing out there?
You know, you're in a firefight.
You need to be on your pig gut getting
rounds down and killing bad guys.
He's like, sir, I'm sorry
I was, I was Winchester.
He had no, you already dumped a
thousand rounds. And I was like, Hey,
all right Mike, you're good, you're
fine. All you want if you go Winchester.
But yeah, I was thinking, how
did I read that? I was like,
you probably weren't too happy about that.
I was so mad.
So mad.
Another thing.
Let me just give you this prompt and
you're going to hear this too. When,
when you,
when you get off this podcast and people
are going to hit you up on social media,
you're going to hear from young soul,
you're gonna hear from
soldiers and marines that are
going to ask you questions
because they listened to this
and they get knowledge from it.
Is there anything that you didn't expect
that you wish somebody would have told
you going into that first firefight?
For someone that's in basic training right
now or at the basic school right now?
Anything that you piece of advice
you'd give them. Yeah, you know,
a few things. You know, one
go in their guns ablazing right away
because in that circumstance the sound is
actually one of your better indicators
are where the gunfire is coming from.
Cause when that heat is blazing,
you're not going to see a muzzle flash.
It's just doesn't exist. Right.
The other thing is when you're,
when you are keeping your vehicles mobile,
that doesn't allow you to lock in on a
t and e system with a heavy machine gun.
So you've got to be smart
in the increments that you
move in and the formations
you move in and make sure that your,
your machine gunners have
drilled that we would do,
we would do t and he drills till my
guy's hands bled and not just the,
the primary machine gunner. Everybody
in that trucks have one goes down,
the other comes up so that it,
when we moved them they can quickly
get back on that same target.
Cause basically what that became a game
of is you suppress that position with a
two 40 golfer, a medium machine gun
until I can talk the tank top on.
And then the tanks, they don't miss. It's
all computer. It's like a video game.
And we'd dug in positions, just aim a
little bit lower and watch the shit fly,
excuse my language. Um, but that,
that was one of the prompts when when we
went in and we started receiving some,
everybody started shooting fire
where we can identify with.
But then also we're getting
shot at from other positions.
We can't really tell because
of the acoustics until
somebody actually hits wait,
waiting.
But we're getting hit for back here too
and then some of the increments might,
my drivers would move in.
They move so much that it was no longer
a small adjustment on the teeny for that
machine gunner.
Now they've got to get out of the turret
exposing themselves to work that thing
in and because of collateral damage,
you can't just work it in,
send some rounds downrange, oops,
I hit the building 10 feet away.
You're not allowed to do that.
You've got to get that sucker into where
you see it on the site and then you can
start sending around down.
Well that guy gets to shoot at you because
you're so concerned with collateral
damage. And so drill, drill,
drill because a mortar,
drop it on the top of a of a Humvee
is not a good thing and they are more
accurate than you realize that these,
the enemy out there has been launching
mortars in indirect fire for decades
where you get a little bit of Ammo
to do it on range 400 out. You know,
I'll out in the,
out in the palms from marines edits these
guys get to do it everyday for real.
Yeah. And you know what? They
don't even have to be good.
They'd get lucky one time.
And,
and human life doesn't mean anything
to them, but it means everything to us.
So they get lucky one time and there's,
there's,
that's the way it goes and
that's the way combat is. Um,
okay.
So you get done with that and,
and tank hits an IED.
You need to find out what's going on.
And basically there's a,
there's a burning Abrams here going on.
Suddenly a huge explosion drowned
out all other battle sounds.
The ground rolled and shook as if the
fault line had suddenly collapsed beneath
us ahead. A maelstrom of sand, dirt,
smoke and flames boiled skyward before
I could even ask Sergeant Peterson's
voice came over, the radio mortar hit one
of the tanks, my column break to a stop.
The explosion morphed into
a dry eye into a small,
dirty brown mushroom cloud
over staff sergeant plump keys.
[inaudible] no way a mortar did that.
That had to have been massive IED.
Luke Miller called over to me.
I have no comms with them.
So now you radio for a med evac.
You're trying to find out what's going on.
The tanks on fire and here we go.
Back to the book,
I took a deep breath and
ran for the burning Abrams.
I took only a few steps before I saw a
Robertson frantically waving back at me.
We are sorry,
waving me back.
Just then a line of bullets stitched
across the sand about 10 feet ahead of me.
I executed my best football shuttle
run and dashed back for cover.
Bravo three laid down suppressing fire,
which allowed me to get across the
open space on my second attempt.
So let's cover moving on another
thing, chapter in the book. So I'm,
I talk about all the time.
This is the fundamental,
there's a fundamental tactic that's
that's what it is. Covered move.
Then you guys are doing it right here.
When
I reached Robertson, he shouted and
we still got two wounded in there.
We had to get the men out quickly.
I climbed onto the tank Miller
following a short time later,
the incoming fire was heavy and more than
once we had to duck behind the turret.
So getting your,
getting your game on Brian Stann kid.
The funny thing about it was I was trying
to maintain a low profile when I got
in the tank.
There's things,
there's little micro things you can hide
behind and the drivers that the person
deepest in that thing and we couldn't
get him out. He was the last one and,
and he was a bigger guy and I'm,
I'm trying to lift them as strong dude.
And I lifted way till I was
in Iraq and Al is a strong,
bigger guy than I am right now.
Couldn't get him out and I couldn't
and I couldn't understand why.
And he's looking at me, he's, he's
got blood all over me. It's like,
why is this taking so long? And he
doesn't say it that clear. I mean he's,
he's out of it.
I didn't know at the time he was
paralyzed from the chest down there.
And so I realized the only way I'm
getting him out is if I get my legs
underneath me and that's
going to create a target.
And so we think sometimes we
think some silly things in combat.
And I just thought, look, if I'm
going to get shot by these guys,
what's the last thing I want
them to see before they hit me?
And that's my rear end. So when I hopped
up, I, I faced that rate towards the foot.
I honestly think, I think
it would save me, you know,
you'll talk to two people that hunt
and they talk about when they get that
perfect buck in their sites, huge
rack. And it's such an easy shop,
but they're so excited that they
pulled a shot and they miss well,
when I've got a Kevlar helmet on,
I look who's seen Spaceballs
well, yeah, I mean,
you can see right now it's just the
headset. When I've got to Kevlar on,
I mean if someone's trying to snipe me
or they're trying to shoot at me with a
medium machine gun and they see, they're
like, oh man, I got this dude they missed.
And I squat, I was able to pull them
up and we literally, you know, we,
we almost collapsed off the tank and,
and landed on top of another
guy and got him down. Um,
but the only thing I could think of,
I mean obviously grateful when we landed,
Hey, I don't think I got
shot. Did you get hit?
He didn't get hit and we were able
to get them out. But that was,
that was what I think happened is
sometimes you just get lucky and I think I
presented such a big target,
whoever was behind that trigger
just straight delusion. Yeah.
That's a nightmare too. I'll tell you
when, when this enemy sees a down vehicle,
it is like a bullet magnet. The fact
that you survived that is ridiculous.
And yeah, it must, it is a miracle and
luck and everything else because when,
when the enemy sees a
target like that man,
they just pour fire onto it cause
they know there's creating a total
catastrophic situation for us. And they
almost always have a camera on it too.
Yeah. I mean they are there for film.
It, it didn't, I couldn't find it.
But they study film, like
NFL teams, study film,
and sometimes you find their footage
where they didn't even attack you.
They're just watching what your response
was to see what they're going to do
next. People underestimate the evil
and the detail that they go through.
Maybe Akhmed the sniper decided to delete
that video because he was going to get
in so much trouble for this
and the big heading of America.
How did you visit this guy?
Look at the size of
a,
so you call him actually,
you called an a helicopters.
They come in under fire.
Don't take any hits.
Somehow miraculously have been,
I've not been able to find
who was flying that Huey.
I never was able to find out and I mean
I wish I could that that guy who landed
because a whole squad was taken out a
few clicks to our east and there was no
med evac birds and this guy,
I mean we laid down in the butterfly
trigger so that he could land, but man,
he showed some guts.
He would've been fired had they got hit.
It had that halo going down,
but he didn't care.
He knew there was a marine there that
needed to get out and need to get out now
or else he was done and, and he
landed, got him and lifted off.
And I never saw him again. I'm telling
you that that's, that's a real,
I was a marine corps as a marine pilot
and in a Huey of all things a Huey,
um, that took some stones and I wish,
I wish I could find that person,
hear this podcast reach out.
So I hope so.
Now you get that back
to base helacious run
and
you guys get back. Yeah.
Great. We survived.
And then you get re tasked,
you got to go bring ammo weapons or sorry,
Emma water fuel back up there.
[inaudible] and
this was an interesting, I got this
and I kind of brought it up earlier,
but back to the book,
just before we rolled out my alpha section
arrived back at [inaudible] after a
very dull day covering the jump off
point for the assault force tasked with
crossing the afraid he's,
they encountered no opposition.
And my Bravo section. Marines quickly
busted out the stories of our busy day,
much to the jealousy of
the rest of the platoon.
This is what I was trying to explain
earlier. So these guys, you know,
these guys were in a crazy firefight,
almost get killed.
They got guys getting wounded,
they come back and the other other squad,
he had no action and what are they?
They're jealous and mad
alpha section was so full of aggressive,
angry marines who wanted nothing
more to get into the fight.
They lobbied to go out on this run.
But I vetoed the idea.
Sergeant Pete's men knew the terrain
now and we needed that experience to
shepherd the two trucks to the bridge.
I told my alpha section it and plenty
of opportunities in the days to come,
but I knew as we left the
wire, they remained on the
base. Frustrated and anxious.
That's just tells you
what the Marine Corps
is all about. Hated me
that night, I'm sure.
And then, okay, so you do, that's
another hell run. And again,
I'm not going to read your entire book.
People can buy this book and
read it,
but when you get back again,
another just crazy run. When
you get back, guess what?
You got to go back to the bridge again.
Okay,
that's good times. So here
you go. Back to the book.
We're going back to the bridge tonight.
I started Alpha,
sat out the last couple of fights.
They were fresh and eager and ready.
Go in the fray right now.
Bravo section had all the bragging
rights and that was driving Francis's men
nuts. When I broke the
news, I like this park.
When I broke the news I saw
no fear in anyone's eyes.
Just anticipation and excitement.
Be careful what you wish for.
I thought
so again,
marines are fired up to
go and you go out again
and this one again goes sideways.
You,
you're using up all your nine man. This.
This one got ugly quick and you know,
we expected it to,
but there was,
there were things working against us a
little bit in that we had to go up there,
the tank that had the
catastrophic hill days earlier,
we had to go up there and recover it.
You can't leave that in the battlefield.
And so I had never even, I had never
known what a Mike 88 recovery vehicle was.
I learned that in Ramadi as well.
It's,
it's a tank with no guns and it's
basically it's, it's a mechanic vehicle.
They go fix the other
tank or they told him,
and so we were going
to meet a tank section,
so to regular Abrams tanks plus this Mike
88 tank recovery vehicle in the middle
of the desert. Here's, here's
your grid. We'll meet there.
I'm going to kick my order there. I've
never even met these marines before. Hey,
by the way, here's your introduction
to my alpha section, by the way,
to we're going to head straight north
and try and catch them by surprise and,
and get right up to the
bridge. But I told them, look,
this area has been heavily guarded,
so be prepared.
Well this master started, who's driving
the mic? 88 lets me know, hey sir,
just so you know,
once we get on that ass fall,
this thing only going to go
about 10 miles an hour at best.
What as you started wait one,
we're good on sand when we don't go very
fast on on asphalt and like well you
don't want to go on sand.
You know what they buried in sand force
and what they have waiting for us there.
So man we hit the line of departure.
We had north and they opened up
on us and that my kth is crawling,
crawling and my section
leader steps are in France.
His vehicle gets hit with an
RPG just missed by an IED,
but the back of the vehicle is on fire
and, and when we're getting hit to tank,
start returning fire.
And here's another really good lesson for,
for young officers and and and just
young service members in general.
When you're fighting at night and you
got night vision goggles on and and tanks
are returning fire into these buildings,
right? They were shooting down on us.
And these buildings shooting has to
windows to the tanks or identity.
We're identifying targets and
they're taking them out the debris.
It's heavy that the material
that these buildings are made of,
it's very heavy in a blindness.
Couldn't see now because all the damage
that tanks did and my lead vehicle blew
the turn back of the vehicles on fire.
They blow the turn.
So we all blow the turn and link back up.
And now as I looked
down the block headache,
it's see these lights Blinken
which typically tells us
it's signaling an ambush.
They're expecting us to go
that route now, decision time,
and you gotta be quick. So at that
time we're about to, we're going, hey,
let's turn the company around.
Let's hit the turn where we know we're
going to get right to the people that
need us right to that down tank. Let's
fight our way through this kills, oh,
let me call.
And some air strikes that time is when
they let loose those suicide vehicles and
one got through our
perimeter and man, I've, I've
one of the Marines actually
filmed that explosion and
just a horrible femi.
I heard that explosion and just the
first thing went through my head.
I just got five kids killed immediately.
It's the first thing that went through
my head radio silence and everybody's
waiting for, there's no crying, there's
no morning, there's no time out.
There's no hey staffs are and
Robertson. You take over. No,
I mean after that thought,
my next,
my next thing needs to be me giving
orders out of my mouth and moving people
forward because we don't have
time to mourn right now. And,
and so immediately I set a
perimeter with the tanks.
I established which vehicles is going to
be the tow vehicle for our down vehicle,
where the casualties going to go.
Where's the corpsman?
And I get out of my vehicle
and I pushed it to leaders.
Do we go to the point of friction?
Where's the point of friction?
And that was my vehicle was just hit with
a suicide vehicle. Man, I'd get there.
And on top of it is this 22 year old kid,
Jeff Lampson was built like
a number two pencil, right?
He was just in this vehicle.
I mean this vehicle is destroyed.
How he's conscious,
I don't know,
but he's on top of it pulling our gunner
out of the turret who's got a piece of
shrapnel in his head
bigger than that book.
Everybody in the vehicles,
everybody's wounded but staff,
certain Francis comes out in the whole
side of his face, his melt and he's like,
sir, we're going to be
good. We're going to be,
I was never more relieved in my life.
They're still getting shot at.
Francis is basically walking but
he's not totally conscious yet.
They're like bullets and I'm a guard.
Like I got to grab and put it behind the
vehicle for a second cause he's out of
it of course.
But man to to see Lampson
this kid who actually,
you know,
had a little bit of an attitude at the
time was one of the guys I had to correct
an awful lot.
Hair's a little too long.
He tried to grow a mustache and peach
fuzz mean he's a kid. You look at the,
I mean, you would never imagine that this
is a warrior, but in this time of need,
I'm telling you man,
he was saving lives and it was so
humbling and so motivating to see that.
And we were able to, we got everybody
in that Mike 88 eventually got the toe,
got out of there and I mean called in a
massive air strike and, and, and we won.
But we didn't pitch a shutout,
that's for sure. And in that,
the hardest part of that was when all
my casualties are loaded on, you have,
we're not doctors,
we have no idea.
When you see a guy with shrapnel
out of his brain like that,
you think they're done.
So my marines,
they think we may have lost two or
three of these folks and they're down.
And as far as I know, we're out there
to fight for the three, four, five,
six that was gas, right? That was shrapnel
was head. Was He, was he walking wounded?
Was He, so he would, he would come to,
he got shot as Lampson was
pulling them out of the Turret.
He got shot again in the elbow
as we were pulling them out.
And we got him to the medivac and, and
he was just, he was, I remember he was,
he was cursing.
I can't believe I let them get us.
I can't believe I let them get us
blaming himself for the suicide vehicle
getting to the vehicle. And I told
him, it's not you, it's my fault.
It's not your fault. And, uh, but
at least he was talking. Yeah.
But I mean this, I, you know, this is,
this is pretty freaky when you see a
piece of metal in someone's head just like
this. And I don't, he couldn't see himself
and I had nobody wanted to tell him.
Nobody wanted to say, hey, reach up and
touch within your brain right now. Um,
but he was gone. I mean,
once he left that day,
we didn't see him the rest of the
deployment. I didn't see him until,
till I had gotten back.
And the craziest thing is
we reunited for an episode of
ultimate insider with the UFC.
And I didn't really know what they
were after. And this, this producer,
you know, asked me if I could get this
guy there, you're going to do a story.
It was really going to be honorable to
him, this and that. And, and it was right.
But at the same time,
he sit in this next to each other
and he's asking this marine, hey,
do you blame Brian Stann
for this happening? Do you
blame this for him? I mean,
it was, it was, it was dark and
it was difficult. And it was,
it was hard for both of us, man,
because, you know, for gas, it,
he lived right in and he's got a family
now, but that the amount of headaches,
the piercing headaches, this
man's struggles with, you
know, in and out of Comms,
try and text him. I don't know what,
you know, we're, we're numbers at, um,
he's a great warrior, great dude.
But the pain he lives with every day,
I mean, at the, this is never
going away. He had I think,
four brain surgeries after
that four brain surgeries,
unbelievable and he was blaming himself
crazy or yours.
Then you know you,
you kind of wrap up that here.
Going back to the book,
our unit three two marines
is known as the BTO bastards.
In 1943 the battalion took
part in operation galvanic
the invasion of Tarawa Btu
island was the main target of the landing
force and the marines faced and the
entrenched enemy with preregistered
fields of fire on the beaches close.
Either don't know what that is.
That's an actual nightmare when the enemy
already knows where their rounds are
going to land, when they fire them
because it's a worst case scenario.
The first assault waves were nearly
wiped out by machine gun and mortar fires
and they waited through the
lagoon onto the narrow beach.
It took 76 hours to kick clear the island,
which was barely 2000 yards
long and a few score wide.
Over 3000 marines and sailors died or
fell wounded during what became the most
ferocious close quarter battle ever
fought by the United States Marine Corps.
That was the legacy of my unit,
a legacy of determination,
heroism, and stoic resolve in the
face of unimaginable adversity.
On May 10th,
2008 my marines proved they
were cut from the same cloth.
Indeed,
it's so humbling when you watched these
young men from all different walks of
life,
you know,
some of them only citizens in the United
States for a couple of years at that
point. Really diverse backgrounds and
me, it's not a gang full of white people.
I mean it's, it's very diverse.
I mean, they don't care. And Man,
when they're getting shot at,
there was nobody ducking for cover.
Nobody.
They are getting after their,
their love and care for one another,
for the mission,
for people trying to destroy
their way of life. It's,
it's all inspiring to watch their selfless
acts. I mean, what they'll do and, and,
and this was more obviously direct
engagement against an enemy,
right? But, but there's,
I've seen them, you know,
just like Lampson was willing to sacrifice
himself to save Robert Gas. Right.
I've seen marines do the same to save
innocent Iraqi kids the same care that
they had for one another they had for the
people that they were there to protect.
And that gets lost a lot when
people talk about these wars. It's,
it's become cool to paint
our military like we're,
we're this brutal force that's wiped out.
You know,
all these people in these different
countries. I mean these, these were men,
these were men who were
such great professionals,
but under the most extreme circumstances
understood that they could lose their
life and that was a hundred
percent acceptable to them.
If that meant saving
the guy next to him and,
and that it's hard for me to meet somebody
like Michael stray hand or a football
player, famous person, right?
They're all impressive people.
But it's hard for me to meet someone
like that and be like, oh my God,
can I get a picture for Instagram when,
when you've been around 19 2120 year
old kids and these kids don't come from
rich background, right? They
didn't have a whole lot.
There is a reason when the,
when our nation was in two wars,
they decided to sign up and be
infantry in the marine corps. It was,
it,
they,
they will forever be that the greatest
people I've ever been surrounded with.
Yeah. You know, uh, I talk
about that all the time.
The fact that when we were in Ramadi
specifically, you know, here we were,
the special operations guys,
the Navy Seals, whatever,
we, all of us, all of us guys,
we just had such admiration and love
for the Marine Corps and for the army
soldiers that we work with. Those
guys like you said, and, and for us,
we're sitting there, we're
going, man, we've got, we
got infinitely more training,
infinitely more training then a grunt
pass. That's just the way it is.
Like you talk about the budget,
we used to shoot more rounds in a week,
then our Marine Corps
company, we're shooting their
workup. No kidding. Like we,
I saw the numbers. So we get infinitely
more training, we get better gear.
And yet you go down to the government
center and Ramadi or you go down to cop
Falcon.
And you look at those soldiers and marines
that are getting after it every day.
And that's why we just had nothing but
the utmost highest respect for those guys.
And they knew it and that was some nasty
fighting down there to NASA funding in
Ramadi.
Yeah.
I'm going to take us
back to the book here.
Okay.
An Amtrak,
a lightly armored amphibious vehicle.
First platoon three to five
struck a landmine only a
few hundred meters from our
position. So this is another
operation that you're out on.
And this is where we started this
a day off. We heard the explosion,
saw the smoke and flames rising behind
us and then heard the cries for help over
the radio.
Okay.
We couldn't go to their aid.
The bridge had not yet been cleared and
we were almost certain had been mined by
the enemy. Besides, we couldn't leave
our blocking position without exposing,
exposing the left flank.
The track burned as three to fives.
Fellow Marines and my friend and mentor,
Lieutenant Deanna from our weapons
company frantically tried to free the men
trapped inside.
Yeah.
Inside Alpha three I could see this
color drain from my men's faces.
They look absolutely stricken.
Okay.
Then the tracks ready.
Ammunition began cooking off
with each debt nation.
I could see my men flinch.
I ordered everyone to face south. I didn't
want my men to see what was unfolding.
Hearing it over the radio was bad enough.
Five marines died inside the track.
Everyone else inside suffered
wounds of varying degrees.
The driver was pulled from the wreckage,
his face, bloody and missing teeth.
The explosion had his head against
the vehicles front console.
Another marine emerged
with his uniform on fire.
Quick thinking men nearby got him on
the ground and put the flames out with a
fire extinguisher vol.
My experiences in combat,
this is the one that haunts me the most.
The feeling of complete impotence in the
face of such a profound tragedy scarred
us all that day
it gave,
Diana had actually served in Lima three
25 it's a reserve unit out of Columbus,
Ohio before he became active
duty and then became an officer.
He was an enlisted with three 25 and I
remember when when we were starting this
operation in three 25 came to our base,
him bringing some of these, these guys,
hey man, I've been, he grew up with them.
I mean these were his brothers
and now they were firefighters.
They were police officers all brought
together for this mission man.
It was brutal. Absolutely brutal. And I,
I remember hearing a story about this
woman from Columbus who they had lost to
think of it. It was over 20 names
around 22 marines from Lima,
three 25 during that deployment.
And she decided to paint these beautiful
murals murals of each one and they were
so nice at the Marine Corps Museum for
a while, put them right in their foyer,
right as soon as you walk into the
museum there they were and they were big.
And I remember hearing story and then
I was doing a shoot with the UFC in the
Marine Corp when the Marine
Corps is advertising at the
UFC and part of the shoe
is going to be us as fighters.
And then with the Marines going to the
Marine Corps Museum. And I was kind of,
you know,
both sides of the fence on that.
And we walked in and they were there
and I didn't know, I didn't expect it.
And it was really tough because
here I am, you know, I'm,
I'm around these marines and I'm around,
you know,
some of my buddies and Rashad Evans,
Forrest Griffin were there. And I mean,
as soon as I walked in, man, my
eyes filled up with tears, you know,
being given the opportunity to meet
some of these men very briefly.
Then we set off and go. And because
of my relationship with Gabe, Diana,
who was my mentor at the time,
and knowing what he went through that day,
childhood brothers of his and,
and, and him also being helpless,
uh,
and nothing's fair in combat.
We know that nothing's fair and and
you don't have the choice. Again,
you don't have the choice
that gets cleared on that.
Fourth continues to push west so that
we can finish the mission of this
operation. We got to continue providing
our blocking position and that's it.
If you lose focus, more of that's
going to happen. It's, it's,
it's a difficult thing to deal with,
but that's what we signed up to do that.
That's why we have an all volunteer force
and it's the greatest military forces
world has ever seen and it's unfortunate,
but part of it is dying.
We die in battle is that the innocent
people here that live in America don't,
and it sucks and it's painful, but at
the end of the day we, we know when we
sign up,
we know that that is a possibility.
Yeah,
it is. Indeed. Now you had
nine guys wounded from your
platoon. Is that right? From that,
from that whole deployment,
from that couple days. Okay.
Yeah. Here we go. Nine men in a
week. Your, I'll go to the book,
but some of them were the reservists
tankers that weren't technically mine,
but yeah, the loss of so many marines
under my command at eating away at me,
almost to the point where I
suffered a crisis in confidence.
Nine men and week of combat.
What had I done wrong?
What have I done wrong?
What lessons could I learn my mind
obsessed over those questions.
Inside the coc,
I braced for the shit storm.
Captain Ford Phillips, my
company commander, spotted me.
As I came through the door, he swiftly
took me aside. Here it comes. I thought,
Brian, excellent job. You did
everything right out there. Thank you.
My jaw almost fell open.
Those were the last words
I had expected to here.
I greatly admired captain Phillips
and had long since learned.
He always meant what he said.
His words were never designed
to make someone feel better.
They were always designed to make a man,
a better officer,
and a better marine.
Always
his words ease the pain
of the last seven days,
but did not erase the guilt
that I felt to this day.
I questioned the decisions I made that
night. That is the onus of command.
You always bear the responsibility for
those under you when they suffer wounds
or are killed by the enemy,
it is impossible for an officer not to
second guessed himself and own part of
their suffering or deaths.
As leaders,
we understand control.
That is where we operate.
Having it is comfort,
but combat and the enemy strips that away.
At times. Once the bullets fly and
the violent chaos of a firefight,
rains control becomes an illusion.
A platoon commander cannot determine
which enemy bullets we'll strike what
vehicles he cannot select. The moment
when an insurgent triggers an IED,
he cannot dictate who
survives and who doesn't.
All we can do is try and fight back to
try and demolish the chaos with enough
fire power that the
enemy dies or runs away.
Almost everything else is
beyond the leaders control.
Okay?
Those limits of leadership were
never drilled into us at the academy.
When I experienced it for the first
time during Operation Matador,
I came gradually to understand
on an intellectual level,
but in my heart I still wonder if I could
have done something else that might've
saved my marines from harm.
I still spend sleepless nights
replaying every moment in my head,
hoping men like gas and
Jonathan Loewe can forgive me
all part of it. Matt and I, it's,
it's funny you read that passage.
I was up last night, same thing,
two 45 in the morning and, and,
and replaying it and it,
it's not something I would say
there's a negative aspect. People will
hear me say that and I'm like, Oh man,
that's bad. You know, post
traumatic stress or something. No,
it's me being a human being who
cares and wonders and it's hard.
It's never going to go away and
all always wonder that, you know,
would it have been a better
decision to take a left turn in,
in abort the mission at that point?
Should I have tried to get back to the
bridge or if I'd have gone three blocks
up,
maybe there would have been a path we
could have found and put her head lights
on.
There are so many what ifs,
so many what ifs that you go
through as leaders. And if,
if you try to ignore those times where
you spend those sleepless nights and not
think through that to get makes it worse.
I think the fact that I'll go
through the drill like last night,
which is the first time in a long time
that I did. Um, I think part of it,
cause I knew we,
we'd probably be talking about it.
I think it's healthy to do that for
me at least it has been, you know,
it's healthy for me to replay that and
to understand. And, and you know you,
you talked about that moment with my
company commander at Fort Phillips.
I remember that conversation.
And I remember kind of going back at
him a little bit and saying, you know,
I just think if I would've done this
or done that, and he stopped me.
Brian, listen, you did everything right.
You did everything that you could
do out there. And it was, you know,
it was definitely what I needed to hear
because we still had a long way to go in
that deployment and I still had
to go do another one. It was,
it was great leadership on
his part because it gave me,
there was no more second guessing
at that point, you know, because it,
that was not the time to sit there and
start to question my decision and my
instincts in battle that it served
me. Well. Up until that point,
I had a, um, a similar conversation
as a matter of fact with leaf. So,
you know, when, when mark we got killed,
it was a Ryan job who
ended up dying as well,
but he had been severely wounded and Lafe
was down in a combat outpost with his
platoon.
And we got Ryan job had been Kaz evaced
out and now the guys are down at this
combat outpost and the army who
are the one, three, seven, um,
bulldogs Bravo company,
who we had an amazing relationship with.
Captain Mike Bama main gun.
Mike,
they were out trying to try to get after
it and they got to a point where he
said, hey, we think we know where
these guys are that shot. Ryan,
do you, can you guys help us? I mean,
it was like the day of fighting
and Lafe called me up on the,
on the radio and says, Hey,
w w w I want to go back out.
They think they know where these guys are.
I want to go back out. And I was like,
go,
go get some.
And he went out and you know,
they were under heavy fire and that's
what mark got killed. And you know,
leaf was, you know, he, he was, you know,
the mission gets done and all that. But
next day leaf comes to me and he says, um,
you know, hey, hey Jocko,
him, you know, he was tore up,
you know, he was tore up his,
his, his friend, his
brother was, was dead.
His other friend was severely wounded.
But what really got to him
was mark because you know,
he'd made this decision to go back
out and he said to me, you know,
I just don't know if I you,
I don't know if I made the right decision.
And I said to, I said to him, [inaudible]
there was no decision to make.
There was Americans out there fighting
in the streets trying to get after these
guys that had wounded one of your guys,
one of our guys,
and they thought they knew where he was
and they thought you could go and get
them.
There's no decision to make.
You don't have to have a
choice in that situation.
You do what you do as an
American, as a seal, as a frogman.
There was no decision.
You did what we do.
And I think that's
something that any leader,
when you get your young leaders out there,
no,
obviously if they screw something up,
obviously that's a different story.
But you know,
we don't have the luxury of knowing
what's going to happen in to combat
situation. There's no crystal
ball. There's no do you don't know.
Like what you just said,
guys would say that stuff to me sometimes.
Like you could've gone left or right. Oh
really? Cause if you could've gone left,
like you just talked about and he had
a giant ID and now everyone's dead,
you could've gone straight and you
could have gotten clear. You don't know.
You don't have that luxury in combat.
You're making decisions based on the
information that you have at that time.
You don't know all this other shit yet.
If you knew it. Obviously looking back,
hindsight is 2020 we wouldn't have
even gone there in the first place.
But we don't know that. The only
way to avoid any risk is not to go,
is not to do your job is to
just go ahead and stand up,
raise your hand and say I'm a coward.
That's how you can avoid these situations.
But
guys in the Marine Corp
guys in the seal teams,
they don't raise their hand and say
that they raised their hand and say,
where's the bad guys?
We're going to get them.
Okay.
And one of the mistakes you can make too,
is sometimes you want
to stop,
you want to think about it.
Sometimes there is no
right answer right there.
There's a bunch of things you can do.
There's a bunch of options and whatever
one you take and maintain tempo and
achieved tempo and stay a step
ahead of the enemy is the right one.
It's how you execute it. Yeah.
Either way you could be going into,
into a bad day, but you better do
it your way in on your terms. Yeah.
One thing that's guaranteed to turn into
a bad day is sitting there and not do
nothing happens.
Because I'll tell you what,
if you're not maneuvering the
enemy's maneuvers, we are.
If you're not maneuvering the
enemy's absolutely maneuvering.
They're getting their flanking you,
they're getting a high ground,
they're doing something. So you better
just be inaction, taking action,
make a decision and go. Especially on
their turf, their tour, their cities,
their neighborhoods. They know
every corner, we're guessing.
Yeah.
So now you come back, you, you, um,
I'm fast forwarding to where
you're now becoming a company XL.
I'm going to the book.
Just after we deployed again in 2006 I
was pulled from weapons company to become
an executive officer for India company.
Three two marines. It happened so fast.
I didn't have time to get know my new
marines before we ended up in country
again.
We deployed to Al Anbar
province to a fob near Haba Nia,
and this was cool because you are in
Habbaniyah and I was 20 miles away in
Ramadi and in that summer of 2006
yeah,
next,
my company last four Marines killed.
Okay.
Lance Corporal Don Champ
Champlin was our first.
He was killed by a roadside bomb on
the main road running through our area.
That was the end of August of 2006 a
month later on the 24th our company
commander sent a platoon out after an
insurgent who'd fired a rocket into one of
our patrol basis.
They'd gone out without a special
device that blocked incoming cell phone
signals and prevented in surgeons from
remotely detonating Ids. Sure enough,
the platoon got hit with a bomb.
Okay.
Blue Lance Corporal Renee Martinez,
70 meters into the air.
He died instantly.
That one really hurt.
I'd been on the base at the time. I took
great pride in going out on patrols,
not to ride herd on
the platoon commanders,
but to be there as an additional asset
and to share the risks with my marines.
Okay.
This time I'd been tied up and
couldn't get out there with the men.
Yeah.
When I heard what was happening,
I grabbed a Humvee and race to the scene.
We carried Renee back to the
morgue inside. I stood next to him,
held his hand and said my goodbyes.
Okay.
I will carry the guilt of that
day for the rest of my life.
Okay.
I should have been out
there with that platoon.
We kept taking casualties that fall.
Even units just passing through
our area got hit. One EOD,
Rick got hit with a roadside bomb build.
The blast didn't destroy the
armored Humvee. It set off a
phosphorus based incendiary
grenade grenades.
The EOD team had left on
the floor of their rig
before we can even get to them.
The white hot chemical fired
melted them where they sat.
The site was indescribable.
After that scene,
morale in the company plummeted.
The men question the mission.
What was the point?
We were getting shot at almost every day.
Going into he had a patrol was a daily
nightmare of snipers, bombs and bushes.
Half the time we couldn't even fire back.
The rules of engagement were so strict
that if civilians were in the area,
we could not engage the enemy.
Since there were almost
always civilians in the area,
our marines had to show
incredible restraint even as
they watched their brothers
die.
Okay,
so you guys were wrapped
that Roe Roe was tight.
It was tough. I mean it was how many,
it had never been patrolled before.
They had set up patrol basis,
but they had never gone out and
walked around in in it. You know, the,
the outgoing unit said, you don't want
to do that. You don't want to do that,
but you had to.
The only way,
the only way to defeat that enemy was
to suffocate the area and what mattered.
Most of the people, if the people trusted
us, they would feed us the information.
So we get captured the enemy if that
people trusted them because we wouldn't
patrol and we were scared, then they
would trust them and we would end up,
we would end up not accomplishing our
mission. And it was, it was so hard.
You know, people have this idea that
because you were a certain rank,
everybody's going to listen or to hardcore
leadership and in they're not going
to ask questions.
You know,
when I would go patrol base to patrol
base and speak to my men and they would
ask, why, why should I
walk out there tomorrow?
You know,
we don't have CNN and,
and this general or the president talking
to us, given us this big huge, hey,
here's the ultimate game plan over.
We don't get any of that. I mean,
my guys were showering once
every 1718 days. That's it.
We were living amongst the populous
amongst the enemy that was traveling all
around the country, coming in
and, and, and, and attacking us.
And so it got really difficult.
But the one thing that that stuck with
them that they could understand that at
their perspective they got was,
hey, look, if you quit on me,
that's one less guy to man the post on
top of this patrol base to keep this
roadway clear.
It's one less guy garden Mikey's flank.
When you go on patrol and you
got three patrols tomorrow,
we were already so thin at that time.
Our battlespace was way too big
for us to truly suffocate it,
to make sure the enemy couldn't,
couldn't come in and
influence way too big,
but as we got better,
as we secured the area and we focused
really on the main supply route and the
economic of that, the
shops, if we get you secure,
the shops insecure the schools because
the kids couldn't go to school and the
kid tried to go to school.
I'll kind of killed the teachers.
So now we secured the area enough
that the two schools could open.
When we were able to do that,
then the shops opened up and the people
could start living their lives again.
That was one of the proudest days of my
marines lives when those kids could walk
to school again,
these schools were corners blown
up from iads bullet holes in him.
There were no roofs. I mean they
were by our standards in America,
you wouldn't be able to
fathom what these look like.
They were basically concrete squares with,
with really bad desks in them.
The school supplies they had
were given to him from us.
And so that was a huge win for us.
And at that time was right around the
same time of the search when the surge
took place.
What happened was two Iraqi companies
pushed west and we're able to take up a
quarter of our battlespace,
which then greatly allowed us now.
Now we've got enough people.
Now we can really influence it.
What happened with the Iraqi people who
you would sit down and have dinner with
them and bring them gifts and talk to him?
I'd have meetings with them at two in
the morning when they felt comfortable to
speak to me. Now they're telling
me who, where, what time,
where can we get them? And when you've
got marines question the mission,
then all of a sudden you deliver them
some intelligence hae at 3:00 AM you're
going to go find this person at this spot.
This is what they look like,
this what they're called, get
them. Then they get excited,
and I don't mean get him is in terms of,
hey,
they're going to go and they're
going to go kill that person.
They're going to go capture them.
And we had a whole process.
That whole very frustrating do
you had to literally now, now my,
my regional longer instrument. Now
they're also detectives. All right,
so this is the Intel package
that led to this detention.
Here's the paperwork for the detention,
and we delivered them
to the detention center.
If you don't hit every wicked right,
that person's back on the
streets and three days.
So that was also detailed discipline
and doing all the right things.
But they did it. And I
tell Ya, Ramadi, Hibernia,
they were some of the worst areas
in Iraq that fall by Christmas time.
It was amazing. The turnaround
was incredible. They were
quiet. They were quiet.
It was, it was, you know,
I left the,
I left October 21st,
2006 there was 30 to 50 enemy attacks a
day while I was in deployment that six
months,
by January there was like one or two
enemy attacks a day down from 30 to 50.
It was boom. It was
incredible, incredible and blog
than February,
February of 2007
in it,
beacon to common home,
third battalion,
second marines came home in 2007
after suffering 15 killed in action.
It could have been far worse for all
of us if we hadn't seen any progress in
hominy.
And that's what you're talking then all
those questions we had over the mission
and its value would have returned home
to term torment us for years to come.
In fact,
we did see progress and that made
it a little easier to accept things.
And um,
yeah, that's, that's basically what
you just said and that's why, you know,
you and I were talking about
this on the way over as,
as nice as it was that we
got to see that happen.
There was nothing more sickening to me
than to have eight years later have the,
the black flag of isis flying over the
city of Ramadi at the government center.
That debt, it was just absolutely heinous
to see that it didn't need to happen.
And
okay.
You know,
they actually took Ramadi back again
through massive air strike and I was
talking to one of my buddies that was
a j Tac that's actually coming on the
podcast Marine Corps, Jay Tac then I was
talking to you about earlier, but he's,
I was like, how many bombs did we
drop in Ramadi while we were there?
Because it was a populous city.
There was normal Iraqis that want to live
their lives. We weren't dropping moms.
He was like, I don't know, maybe a dozen,
15 in the second portion to Ramadi that
the Iraqis just did behind the strength
of American firepower.
You know how many air missions they did?
They did 600 strike missions.
And you've seen pictures of
Ramadi right now it's rubble now.
They're rebuilding it now, but it
was just, just, just rubble and um,
yeah, just, it's so disheartening. Um,
so you come home from that deployment
and pretty quickly after you got,
you got home that Travis got
killed. Yeah. And, uh, you know,
I wanted to give a little credit here
to the Mitt teams because Travis was a
Mitt team, uh, which is military
transition team, which was, okay.
So I talk about this sometimes, right? So
the seals and a special operations guys,
a lot of times we live in
relative comfort. Okay.
So we live like, okay, we're pretty
comfortable. You know, like I said,
I had Max on deployment,
I brought a GP medium tent to put massive,
cause I got to train some Jujitsu.
We have a nice weight room, you know,
wheat and seals are super aggressive
and crafty and figuring out like, okay,
what can we do? How can we get this?
We'll Barb contractors and ordering stuff.
And so we just make, we do a good
job of building our infrastructure.
And when I say infrastructure, I mean
some, some comforts come with that.
Right now you go to the conventionals,
take a step down because they're
not getting as much leeway.
They don't have as much. Uh,
they can't get away with as much,
so they're living maybe a little bit
harder, maybe even a lot harder then.
And of course a,
by the way,
there's special operations guys that
are living out in the sticks and
Afghanistan with two of them with, you
know, 280 tribesmen. So I'm, I'm saying,
I'm talking about my particular situation,
which my particular situation was in Iraq
when I deployed there. We always lived,
always lived good conventionals
we'd go out to their outstations,
we'd stopped on a way to a mission.
We'd stopped by someone, you know,
stop by wherever, some cops
somewhere or some fobs somewhere.
Those guys are living rough.
And I had seals,
my seals that lived in Craig
it or they were living rough.
But my point is you go one step further
and now you get to what called the Mitt
team. And the mid teams are
embedded with Iraqi troops.
And so they are living with Iraqi
troops. There might be two, three,
maybe four of them. And they're out
there living with the Iraqi troops,
counting on the security of the
Iraqi forces to protect them.
And I mean it was horrible. When we
first got to Ramadi, there was a,
there was a VB IED attack that killed
the oncoming Mitt team commander and the
outgoing Mitt team commander,
they're doing a turnover at
a station and a Vb IED came,
killed them both wounded a bunch.
But it's interesting cause I didn't
know Travis was a supply officer in the
Marine Corps. And so, so the,
the Marine Corps has this
way of selecting where you,
where you get what you get to be
in the Marine Corps as an officer.
They take the class and chunk
it up into thirds and then the,
the each top third you get a
pick and it goes down the list.
So that way they don't have every
single guy, eh, all the best guys,
quote unquote going to be Marine Corps
and three are going to be a pilot.
You might be,
you might be the bottom,
the top of the bottom third in the class
and you get your pick. So you don't,
it doesn't matter how you perform.
I mean it matters.
But out of a class of over 200 Travis
was 17 in his class at the basic school,
which is a very prestigious,
they'd be due to graduate
in the top 25 is incredible.
And he got his third choice
is 30 is a logistics officer.
He was furious.
So he's angry.
And then the, and the Marine
Corps did this very, very well.
They understood the
importance of the Mitt team.
So they really took great guys and
send him to the Mitt teams and he,
so they put up volunteers, hey, who wants,
who wants to raise your hand and go live
amongst the Iraqi's counting on them
for security training them, working
with them, eating their crappy food,
living without air condition mean. It
just sucks. It just sucks. It's awful.
Of course. What does Travis to,
Oh, I'm game. Let's do this.
So he went and uh,
obviously he was, he was,
he was killed in action.
He was killed in action during a firefight
trying to, like you just talked about,
wasn't trying to save other marines.
He was trying to save his fellow Iraqi
soldiers. And just like you just said,
there's so many people
that don't understand how
closely we worked with Iraqi
soldiers and how committed
we were with helping them.
So that's a classic example.
And by the way,
that that eulogy
that he wrote for himself
was this Travis Mannion was a man on
afraid to stand for what was right.
I think that's something that
anybody could aspire towards.
And, and actually another, you know,
you talked about the connections earlier.
Well there's a connection
here that Travis,
his roommate in the Naval Academy,
it was a guy by the name of Brendan
Looney who did what you talked about the
painful way of getting to the seal teams.
He went to the surface warfare community.
Then he got picked up for the seal teams,
went through seal training and he was
also killed in Afghanistan 21 September,
yeah.
But you come home from that deployment
and now you've got, you're married,
you got one daughter, you're expecting
another daughter. And by the way,
this whole time, like we
talked about earlier, you've
been fighting MMA training.
You fought,
your first pro fight was
between deployments and
you're amateur fights we're
going to talk about was before your
first deployment and you make a decision
that all right,
you're gonna get out of the Marine Corps.
And obviously this is probably the hardest
decision you've ever had to make it
year at that point,
your roto brutal,
but
it's 2007. How much are you, were you,
were you thinking at that time like a,
I'm going to go for this MMA thing
and it's gonna it's gonna be,
I got a shot at making it,
you know, it was, it was, I knew
I had a shot at you must have,
you had a shock cause your ass
was undefeated at this point.
Of course, the worst thing that
could have happened, right? I mean,
the worst thing I'm training with,
so I would basically go around the
base and I found this corpsman with
cauliflower ear. Hey, how'd
you get that? Koffler uh,
champ at an Oklahoma wrestling in high
school. Boom, be here 1800 every night.
Got It all, bring you gear. Cool.
He was in and he then started
training with a started fighting.
But I got a wrestler dude right now
they're cuter, wrestled. Hey you do,
you're a blue belt in Jiu Jitsu.
You're my instructor master.
But he was my master. I had no
striking coach. We had no pad work,
no nothing.
It was me and a couple of marines plus
a corpsman and we would get after every
day.
And then every time we fought we won.
So we thought we really
knew what we were doing.
And I would take leave every once in
a while I take leave and I would go to
extreme couture for a couple of days and
get destroyed. I went out to Temecula,
to Dan Henderson's place,
I'd go get destroyed and I just
try and learn to moves. Right.
Give me two moves.
So here I am in the WC again.
Armbars from the mount arm bar
from the guard dose. I know it.
Half Guard is now,
can't sweep a soul from it though.
What Mola Wall showed me how to defend
a single leg and double leg when I was
out of Temecula.
So now I got that down pat and I still
got a mean jab cross away we go baby and
I'm winning fights with these things
and you know I would end up losing the
first time it WC and that would
prompt me to to leave Georgia,
go find somewhere to train and I'll never
forget my first training session at at
Jackson Winklejohn Academy and I'm there
training and Greg Jackson comes walking
up to me after my first practice and
this is as polite as he could try to cop.
Let me at the time Brian,
I am so amazed at how far you've gone
with how little information you've been
given a code word. Wow, you suck.
How the Hell did you win?
One of the things I
explained, I said, look,
when you only know so much you can
fight 150 miles an hour cause you're not
thinking. Then all of a sudden I'm
learning all these new techniques.
Then I started thinking I had an up and
down period there where win some lose
some. And I got to a point where
after the Phil Davis fight, Hey,
you may be out of here.
You know the UFC wasn't a huge fan of me.
They didn't really care.
They didn't, you know,
Joseph wasn't a huge fan of these
WVC guys that were forced upon them.
That wasn't a talent.
He went and found it and I told him I'd
fought three times inside of six months
and I said, look, I need a break. And,
and I literally looked at my MMA training
like you would look at the training of
a marine company. Where am I
weak? How much time do I have?
What am I going to schedule?
What am I going to do? Who Do,
who are the experts I can go to
to get better in all these areas?
And I approached it. I I knew
at that point, hey look, I
still had a fulltime job.
I never fought without one
transition to the marine corps,
started working at a company called Med
assets. Med assets had this, this project,
this thing,
hey hire heroes when to help vets get
jobs will maybe you could lead that took
that over. So I'm working every
day but at the same time, you know,
I started this thing in MMA and I can't
go out like this to many people said I
was going to wash out, that I was going
to be exposed, couldn't do it. No Way.
There were too many marines at the time.
Taking pride in my performance is in
there and although I was older, yeah,
I'm 20 probably 29 at that time. So
in terms of MMA age, I'm already,
I'm green and I'm already
kind of getting a little old,
but I started to find a way
starting to figure it out and, and,
and not cutting any corners like
other fighters were at the time,
but starting to figure it out.
And it all just came down to discipline
where a lot of martial artists don't
want to spend time,
they don't want to spend 30
minutes drilling one move
and understanding how they
could use that move from various
positions and why it works.
And how it plays into my style of
fighting, why it will effective.
They want to drill that one move,
they want to do it five times and then
they want to go live. Let's go live,
let's go live.
And I had alerted that point if I'm
going to catch up with these fighters who
are younger in many cases,
but much more experienced than me.
I have got,
I've got to take an analytical approach
and an honest approach to my skillset
and start to shore up some holes or else
I'm going to continue to lose practice.
Just wrestling like crazy. And then
submission avoidance. It was, it was,
I actually went and put a g
on for the first time ever.
It was working some basics because
everybody wanted to hold me down.
If I could get out from underneath
somebody with a Guianan,
it's gonna be a heck of a
lot easier. Gnocchi, truth,
I was bringing in wrestlers
that were way above my level.
A guy named Harry Lester,
who was, you know,
in the Olympian was coming in and
throwing me all over the place.
And so I was training,
wrestling nonstop and then I would
go and I'd go to Albuquerque.
I didn't have a fight coming up,
but I would go live in Albuquerque for
two weeks at a time away from my family
and help other guys and their training
camps and get exposed in drill and
without, here's the other big part
was guys like Rashad Evans, Keith,
your dean, Joey via Senor, Nate
Marquardt. Without those guys,
it would've never happened because after
they would beat me after they would
pass my guard, take me down,
hit me with this combination,
they would stop afterwards
and tell me how and why,
and so I learned at a much faster rate
than your typical fighter would because
not only am I, I'm drilling with
some of the best in the world,
taking the time to drill and
take an analytical approach, hey,
I know we're going to work this today,
coach,
but my butterfly guard is completely
ineffective and I'd love to work at
specifically not just on sweeping because
I don't think I'm going to get there
yet against my level of competition.
Just get up.
I'd love to use it to get up or even just
get to the fence where now I've got a
third leg that I could utilize to get
back up until we would drill specifics
like that.
And I've got these guys who have 30 plus
fights who are champions now taking the
time to help me, which meant a
lot to me. I'll never forget it.
I mean they were as much coaches to me
as Mike Winkeljohn and Greg Jackson where
you know, and then you know, obviously
on top of you could do all of that.
The other piece of it was when
I would do my camps there,
when I really got where I was at my best,
you know,
when I be Chris leave binge or Santiago,
let's just go.
When I was beating those guys mentally,
I was in the best place.
My family was in it when it
was in a great spot. They were,
my wife and kids were very supportive
of me leaving and doing my camps in
Albuquerque and my time away from them.
It made me nasty. They'd come visit.
But man, I would literally
look at my opponent like,
you're the one who kept me
away from my family this long,
you're going to pay for it. And, and
it was, it was a strong motivator.
And that if you're in a place to
fight or where you're not hungry,
getting new information,
being able to mentally be in the
right place for you to perform.
This is not about who the better
fighter is. It has nothing to do it.
It's about who fights best that night.
And if you can't mentally be in the state
where you're going to fight best that
night, you got a problem and you're
in the wrong place. And that, that,
that phase of my career, that's when I
was, I was there, I was able to do that.
And that was, that was when I
was at my best. For sure. You,
I mean you had some stunning fights.
I know. I always tell, you know,
sometime my fighters will say all, you
know, I'm not, I'm not feeling it tonight.
It doesn't matter. Doesn't matter you
like this isn't training. I'll say, look,
it doesn't matter how you feel
tonight cause a fight night comes,
you might be feeling
good, bad, doesn't matter.
What you have to do is perform right now.
That's what you gotta do.
So train yourself to perform right
now. But yeah, you had some, uh,
you had some great fights. Um, and Chris
Liebing who I know trained with Chris,
great guy and that,
and he's such a tough bastard
and you guys threw down.
Yeah, we knew, we knew neither one of
us are going to be that hard to hit. Um,
but uh,
no tons of respect for that guy.
And that was a fight he
didn't have to take, you know,
I saw an opening there where
there was a window and,
and he made just take me as a, as a
fight to, okay, let me go get a win,
get some money and,
and go on.
Cause he had just come off two huge
wins and like a week or 10 days,
no psycho and so of them,
phenomenal guy in this sport.
And Yeah. You know, it was a wild ride.
I, and when I look back on it, there's,
there's definitely some regrets.
Like anybody there,
there's some things you wish you
wish you could have done. Um,
some things that happened familywise
that certainly stalled and in,
in helped aid the decision to
stop, you know, my wife losing,
losing her little brother to
suicide was a really tough thing.
Her mom was living with us at the time,
so you know,
us going through that tragedy together.
It's hard.
We were human beings and a lot of fighters
have to deal with tragedy and compete.
This is what we do for living.
We've got to fight through it.
It's a hard thing when I look back on it
where I know I was as an athlete and as
a mixed martial arts,
how green I was to have come that far
and been a legitimate top 10 middleweight
at that time. I'm proud
of that, especially here,
especially in the era when I fought
were there were some extra curricular
activities going on as well. I'm against
guys that were a lot of guys we're on,
we're on steroids. There was no testing
or there was really limited tests.
It was an Iq test, right? If you
fail that you, you know, you're just,
you're just straight up dumb.
Uh,
but it was fun and I mean the guys you
like, you lost a Chail Sona, right?
Who was two minutes from being the,
the,
the middle weight champion of the world
against Anderson Silva. Uh, you know, you,
you lost to him, you beat
Sacara. Then you lost a Biz Bang.
Who actually is the current
middle weight champion. So,
and the guys that beat you were
bad asses. Yeah, absolutely.
And you were a guy that will like started
fighting three weeks ago. You know,
that's just awesome, man. It's
a testament that, you know,
the coolest part about it was,
was during that time, you know,
in any kind of happened
subtly beneath that, you know,
at least to the fight fans was,
was taken that that little hire heroes
USA project that that company Med assets
asked me to watch over,
right? Step one was,
we're starting to build some programs.
Step two was getting one of my best
friends in the world who served with me,
who is right next to that track as it
burned Nate Smith to come and be my chief
operating officer and build this amazing
team and leveraging some of the media
attention I got for fighting. Leveraging
it for our cause in building it and,
and not just building a company
where, hey, we went out,
we fundraise for a
mission. No, that's bogus.
We were out there
accomplishing the mission,
helping veterans get legitimate jobs,
careers so that they can succeed and
lead again back here home and in their
communities and watching it grow from a
team of five to a team of 10 to a team
of 22 are now we've got 96
full time employees and we're,
we're bringing in over 300 veterans and
spouses a week into the programs and
that that was all built with
this amazing team of people.
While I was still fighting that that
was my full time job doing that and in
having a board of directors that had
the foresight and and the perspective to
say, Hey, you know what? Yes,
you're going to be a little limited
during some of these training camps.
Bought what you're able to bring to our
brand is helpful right now in the phase
at this company is and,
and it's been a wild
and really amazing ride.
And in some of the things we talked about
earlier where you have these things,
these questions that will always haunt
you about the loss of your friends,
the last few marines,
the loss of your seals.
When you can lead an initiative like
that, it helps you feel like, hey,
you know what I am.
I am taking advantage of every day,
every day we're moving forward,
we're achieving,
we're helping other warriors now find
success post military service and,
and that's me earning it,
earning my day where they don't.
They no longer have any,
you know,
Travis may need to live anymore and his
family would give anything to see him
one more time. I can't bring him
back, but I'll tell you what,
if I sat here crying about it,
feeling sorry for myself,
that my friend Travis was gone,
he'd be the first a slap the
hell out of me when I die for,
or at least do double leg on your ass.
He was, I'm telling you me and that,
that was he planned on fighting
when he got done with that women,
he'd still be fighting to this day. He
was a bad, bad dude. And that was your,
your last fight in the UFC. You retired
after you fought Vandelay Silva,
which did you plan no to do that?
So you don't know that aren't MMA?
There's a guy,
a legendary mixed martial
artists named Vandelay Silva.
I saw him fight a few times and we're
in Japan back in the back in the day and
he's a, he's a brawler and
he's incredible punching power.
And his nickname is the ax murderer
because he looks like a psycho. And uh,
anyways,
Brian had a fight with him and
these two guys went in there.
It was like Russian roulette.
It was a street fight.
And eventually you got caught,
you know,
got caught by one of the best strikers
that have ever been in the game. And um,
and that, and by the way, you dropped
him a couple times. You, you had that,
you didn't have it one,
but you definitely,
you dropped him two or three times in
the first round or twice the first one
back from the dead, a minimum
of two times. The eyes were
in the back of his head.
And then he just, he looked at me
again with bloodshot eyes. It was,
it was unbelievable. Unbelievable.
But no, that was not the plan.
And so you with Greg Jackson, wink, right?
Ah,
I wasn't ISO for the,
the other Sacara Bisbing and
Vandelay fight. I trained myself.
And the reason being was,
uh,
right after I had fought shell
son in two days before Christmas,
me and my wife land in baggage claim and
I get a call and in her little brother
who had struggled with bipolar
disorder and depression,
and we didn't know that debt,
right? He had taken his own
life, went up to a cabin,
middle of the woods
and taken his own life,
had to tell my wife there in baggage
claim and her mom at the time was living
with us. It was personal life was a
mess. Still got to pay bills though,
right? You still, it's
still got a company to run.
So I gotta fight career that I've got to
push through and I can't just, hey look,
I'm going to take seven months off here
to get through this because I got bills
to pay anyways.
It,
it caused me to start my own camps so
that the game plan going in was, hey,
we're going to,
we're going to take Vandelay down a
little bit in this fight and disrupt him.
Really, really confused them because
nobody's, nobody's used to me doing that.
And so I fly to Japan,
we get off the plaintiff that long
flight after a long training camp where I
absolutely overtrained and
we get to the hotel and, and,
and me and one of my striking coaches
Mizuna tall, we go start hitting pads,
we're hitting pads and pad works done it.
Oh Man.
All of a sudden I start to cool down.
I can't lift my knee up on my left leg,
tear something in my head.
And it happens, right? I mean,
evangelist could have walked in there and
how many miles he could've walked into
a couple of injuries. So anyways, now
this gets into my head a little bit.
And so I asked to see the UFC doctor
and so he, as soon as he landed,
he was told, hey, you got to
go see Brian Stan. I say, look,
I've looked at all this stuff.
Nova Cain is legal.
I just want to get novacane for
fight night. So I won't feel it.
And I'm walking around the hotel and
I'm trying not to show anybody that I'm
limping at the press conference cause
I have a legitimate limp. And anyways,
he's like, okay, we
should be, we're in Japan,
we're not in a second or third world
country. We're in Tokyo. Right.
I could have walked across the street,
probably got in late.
It can't anyways supposed to get,
it's supposed to get us,
but I'm going to get it on me to
get them to get it doesn't get it.
When you find Japan the fight so that
they could cater the American TV audience,
you leave at like 7:00 AM.
So he's sitting there, sorry.
So I let that affect me
too much mentally and,
and we're trying to warm up backstage
and I'm trying to shoot some double legs
and I'm not feeling it. And in my own
head rate for a walk, I'm like, you know,
up the student, get some miles
on him. I hit like a truck.
Let's get in there. Let's knock this dude
out and let's get this fight over with.
So ready to go walk out there.
And he tags me first,
hits me behind the ear and,
and you know most of vandelays fights,
he's a little bit more
of an accumulation guy.
He's not considered a
one punch knockout guy.
This one right hand he hits me with,
I had never been rocked in the AUC gum
before in my life and he dropped me.
I was like, all right, it's on, let's go.
And so then I rock him and once
I rocked him they thought, okay,
one more good shot on
the chin and he's done.
And I landed it and he'd go down and
then he'd come back and the wait a minute
here.
And so I'm just caught up.
And so the second round I start to get a
little more technical and move around a
little bit. Like, all right,
he's obviously not going away.
I've got to take a different approach.
Well,
I don't know what this guy has made
of. And, and then he, I didn't even,
I don't remember her, you know, I
get caught with that huge punch,
don't remember any of it. And
it's crazy. But I realized I lost,
I came to,
as Jon Anik,
who's one of my closest friends now comes
up to the microphone and I realized,
well, I don't remember
women. So why most losses.
And it was a horrible flight home.
I'm sitting there flying home and
I had a jack and coke in my hand,
couldn't sleep at all, didn't
sleep, and I am miserable.
I lost to a guy who was supposed to beat,
who was supposed to be washed up,
you know, I had pretty much made the
decision then you know, I'm, I'm, I'm out.
It's over. If you're not going
to get busy being the champion,
then there's other areas where that need
my attention more from my family to the
company I'm trying to run and
it was a hard decision and in,
pardon me when I made the
decision thought for sure.
I'm definitely in a comeback, right? I'm,
I'm going to come back
in for like two years.
I held onto that and had to
fight against it. Like, no,
it is not your best interest
to come back anymore.
You do a better job talking
about in the microphone.
Then you're going to do strap and the
gloves on any more pal. You're 35 now.
I'm 36 it's over.
That makes me feel real good over here.
So you know,
we've been going for a while.
Tell us about like specifically
with with hire heroes, what,
how can people support that?
Where do we look for it?
All that stuff so that way people
have information on it. Yes,
we've got a website,
hire heroes usa.org and if you are a
service member or a spouse who needs help
finding a career,
if you're unemployed or underemployed,
you go on there your register and we'll
get you your personal veteran transition
specialist.
Fancy term for a job coach.
And we'll take you through the whole
thing from revising your resume, uh,
to teach you how to effectively do a
job search, how to interview for a job.
We will help you if not build
your linkedin site for you.
Teach you how to use that to
impact and expand your network.
Do social media audits.
Hey,
what pictures and posts as you not have
up on Facebook right now, you know,
take a look. Hey, no big papa pump
at Yahoo is not your email anymore.
It's going to be christinaSmith@yahoo.com
are all the do's or don'ts.
But then we have a job or a
lot of corporate partners.
We'll match you to all those companies,
but we do so people,
if people want to hire a veteran
they can absolutely you as well as,
that's the one thing I get hit
with a lot is you know people say,
how can we help veterans?
And I say hire veterans and they say,
where do we find him? So now we've got
to put good place to find a solution.
Women,
we're bringing in over 300 people a week
in the program who are all going to get
one on one assistance and and
different from any other nonprofit.
Everything we do is tracked,
logged and analyze and salesforce so
that we can hold ourselves accountable.
I can hold every one of my employees
accountable for the workload they have.
They all have weekly, monthly, quarterly
and annual metrics that they have to hit.
They don't hit them,
they no longer work.
Here we run this non profit
like a business because
people donate money to us to
help veterans find careers, period. And
if we're not doing that, then we go away.
And I take that very serious and it's
what's allowed us to grow from a team of
four to now a team of 96
it will continue to do so.
And my main mission now is to make sure
hire heroes USA is there for the next
generation of combat veterans as well
when they return home to a society that
doesn't understand them as
much and in the real help,
the real need is for the veteran to
learn how to communicate their skill set,
how to deliver their value proposition.
It's a hard thing to do.
Think about your seals when they got out,
if they went to a job to
try to write a resume,
what the hell do I put my first resume
looked like I was trying to get a job as
a mercenary.
It was all and I was a Naval Academy Grad.
Imagine these young
sailors, you know, and,
and over 80% of the people we help at
hire heroes or your young enlisted service
members, the ones who need us
the most. Awesome. Awesome.
And then you've got the Guardian
project going on. Incredible project.
And I'd love to to,
to get these guys down.
Ben Kovacs who's our executive director
come down and be on your show some day.
It's, it's so in line with some of your
beliefs on martial arts in Jujitsu.
Ben Has a vision that every kid should
have the opportunity to train martial
arts,
every child check and,
and so he went out network and found a
man by the name of Joel on unfelt who's
on my board at hire heroes who's an
executive at Twitter and they bought a
property in Oakland where there are a
lot of young men and women who don't have
much going on after school and they don't,
they,
that the chips are stacked against them.
Yeah,
there's not a whole lot that
they have, you know, their,
their families have a hard time making
money and there's a lot of trouble they
can get into and they will find them
and they bring them in and they come,
they train martial arts, they
trained Jujitsu, they trained boxing,
they do their homework.
Then they've networked with local
restaurants and they get a healthy meal
afterwards for free. In many cases,
these are, this is the health,
the only healthy meal that that young
man or woman's going to get that day.
They have regular members to the gym,
but those members pay a membership fee.
That also then pays for those young
kids so that they can come for free.
People buy a gift for themselves. Then
they get a freaky for one of the kids.
I've gone there and talk and
ransom classes and it is just,
it's incredible to meet these young men
and women who haven't been given much in
life.
Their parents are grateful because now
they're not paying for after school care.
They can't afford it anyways,
and their kids not wandering the streets,
but now they've got this place to go to
where there's likeminded people pushing
them to do better.
Don't allow your circumstances to direct
and direct your life until you who
you're going to be.
Nothing should hold you back.
So the discipline that they're
learning now, the camaraderie,
that character they're learning
at Guardian is starting
to spill into the other
aspects of their life. Their grades are
going up, they're being more nutritious,
they're focused on their future. Hey,
wait a minute, college, I can go.
I can go to college.
They've got these great
positive inspirations around
him and the goal is to take
guardian from Oakland and start to to to
brand it and get it in gyms across the
country where now we don't need
a physical facility to do it in.
Other gyms can take on the program where
now we've got a system where they can
adopt it and people can pay their
membership as part of a way of paying the
membership to these underprivileged kids
to go there and train afterschool as
well so that they can have a chance.
Just because they're poor doesn't mean
they should get the opportunity to train
Jujitsu,
to train boxing,
to get all the character development
that goes along with martial arts.
That's all I got.
I actually,
I got another book coming out in the
book is called the way of the war,
your kid and it's a kid's book and
it's basically about a young kid who's
getting picked on at school.
He can't do any pull ups. He,
he doesn't know his times tables
and is basically miserable, right.
And anyways,
school ends and his uncle Jake comes
out to stay with them for the summer.
Uncle Jack as a team guy. So uncle
Jake says, oh, you got some issues.
What are the issues? Oh, I can't do pull.
He goes, I, we can fix all those things.
So one of the, you know, obviously
get some working out. Oh,
you're getting bullied because
he's getting bullied badly.
Well guess where he's going to learn?
He's going to learn Jujitsu.
So I honestly think there's going to be
a little bit of a surge of Jujitsu in
America. I love it. And it
sounds like this is right up
there, right up that alley.
It is. You know, when, when that comes
out, we're going to grab a bunch of them,
make it mandatory for these kids,
things like that. Inspire them. I mean,
they make a difference when you look at
the just the social and economic impact,
young man or woman who has a high
likelihood of probably getting arrested,
especially when you look at some of
the problems we have with our criminal
justice system right now. Instead they
have a positive environment and never get,
they go into college and they go get
a great job and they're contributing.
They're winning now.
Huge impact for our country,
for our communities to do that
and and to get more Jujitsu,
more martial arts and some of these,
these poor super rural areas in our
country where there's extreme poverty and
are super urban areas where there's
extreme poverty where these young men and
women don't get that opportunity because
their parents can't pay $150 a month
for them to go and they don't have
any positive influences in their life.
I mean at that,
if that can fix a lot of problems
that we have going on in our country,
there's no doubt does. Is there a way
to help the Guardian project right now?
Go to go to guardian project.org
there's a website right there.
You can become a monthly sponsor.
I mean, that organization is, is,
is in startup phase. If someone could
give five the $10 a month to them,
that is a huge portion of a young man or
woman's monthly membership for them to
go to that gym, get a free meal, have
someone looking at the report card,
tutoring them in math,
teaching them Jujitsu.
Confidence mean that we get young
ladies in there and they're in their,
their confidence when they start
dating and who they choose and how,
I mean the way they're
going to approach life,
these young men and understanding how to
respect and train with the young lady,
Hey, I'm going to grapple with you
this round and how to respect you all.
I mean it's,
it's amazing to watch it's happening
at a young age and how quickly they're
developing. It's awesome.
That's awesome. So hire heroes,
the Guardian project
organizations to support,
and I guess that kind of wraps it with us.
If anybody wanted to support this podcast.
Echo Charles,
I have a question. Oh, echo
comes with a deep question.
Got a question kind of deep.
So when you watch a few good men,
are you like on the side of the Marines?
Like the whole movie?
I'm saying don't group me with them
just because I wear the same uniform.
You know a few good men,
he's going against the navy.
Tom Cruise, the navy guy.
Dude, you're not going to
seal. But you know, so I am.
When I watch a few good men,
I am with the marines all the way up until
they break their integrity. All right,
which it's a movie, right? But,
but under no circumstances should we
break our integrity and and that that's a
problem. They, you know,
that's, it's so false. No,
colonel would tell someone one thing,
then tell this junior guy over here, no,
you go do this and then lie
about and try and cover it up.
Cover a good cover up number when they
break their integrity. That's, I don't,
I don't care what uniform you're wearing,
that that's a problem.
Or if you're not wearing a uniform at all
after we just talked about that on the
last podcast. Maintain the
integrity. It's true. Oh,
follow up question. Is there such
thing as a code red? No. Okay.
There's no sense anyway.
So support, right.
We can talk about that if it was like
cool. Yeah, let's do it right now.
All right, well, uh, and let's do it fast.
We'll will speed it up here.
This top about on it supplements I
worked out today because he probably can
tell. Yeah, you look, the pump
is on it. It's there. So on. Um,
the name of the preworkout is
total strength and performance.
I left out the strength in there,
so you perform good and is strong anyway.
If you want 10% off on it stuff.
Shroom tech,
Alpha brain total strengthen performance.
Good on at.com/jocko Krill oil threatened
me with a Krill oil rage today. Yeah,
it's cool. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that's another story right there.
Anyway, on a dotcom slash chocolate,
that's for 10% off best supplements
in the world. Approved, approved,
approved home.
Um,
also if you shop at Amazon by duct tape,
whatever, um, or the books
really we talk about,
um,
hard for the fight.
You better order this one quick because
I don't think it's in print right now.
And my mom bought off five copies.
My mother bought,
I can't believe you've got one.
She must have resold that on Ebay.
Didn't realize she said
that to you. Yes. Yeah.
Bullies on Amazon though and you can buy
it should and in the event of you doing
that or buying anything else, um, and you
want to support the podcast by the way,
click through the jungle, podcast.com
website or Jocko store website.
So click on the little Amazon banner,
boom.
Then do your shopping and then get
the book or whatever else you get. Um,
and you can support that way. That's
a good way. That's like small action,
big result like sodium in a, in a
fish tank is what we say, you know,
reminds me when we say it,
it's all good anyway.
And then,
you know,
subscribe to the podcast on iTunes
and stitcher and Google play.
If you haven't already. Seems obvious,
but you know, do that. If you haven't,
and then, you know, write a review.
If you're in the mood and you're in the
mood to sports, podcasts, also youtube,
we're putting out more videos now.
I noticed that shorter videos
Jocko. Good. That's one of the, the
Oji videos. That was a good one though,
by the way. Um, I thought, I thought
it was good. Uh, subscribe. Yeah.
Youtube if you like those videos,
if you like little Jocko mcnuggets rather
than the whole podcast all at once.
Shareable, right. I say, Hey Brian
Stann watch this video real quick.
It's two hours long. You're not watching
it real quick. Three minutes long.
You might watch that one real quick.
Absolutely. Same thing. Exactly right.
The same thing. So that's what we're
doing now. If he didn't know. So yeah,
subscribe to that. If you want to, um,
you know, you want to be updated on that.
Also, Jocko has a store,
it's called Jocko store,
Jocko store.com. We think of original
names like that. Simple, but you know,
got still name like Jocko, why change
it up? Yeah. Yeah. It's perfect.
And you know, there's some
shirts on there, you know,
if you want to kind of
get after it that way,
get yourself a shirt that's kind of,
you know, you're wearing shirts anyway,
I figure, right? Yeah. Why not
wear a Choco shirts anyways.
Right,
exactly
right. I agree with you make
of that and they're good.
That we kind of wait is this has to be
one discipline equals freedom. Yeah.
Discipline equals e. That's an
awesome shirt. There you go. See that?
That's an awesome shirt. Approved. If
there's a London wearing those shirts,
pretty legit doesn't,
I'll show you something like that.
You know what you do just don't
want to wear the shirt. Yeah.
You want to go ahead and live the life
you've been in there for a discipline.
Like if you're going to do that,
don't wake up at 10 30 in the morning and
roll out of bed on a city. No, no, no.
Go accomplish something.
Yup. Very well put. Yes. Um, so
yeah, check out those shirts.
I'm not saying buy a shirt,
I'm just saying I'm not sitting here and
saying buy a shirt. I'm saying go ahead.
Go on the website, junk
store.com. Look at the shirts.
If you like the shirts and you
want to support the podcast,
get a shirt, it's on you. Um, there's
some rash guards in there so you can,
you know, some, some physical
activity, grappling, surfing,
crop, anything that, you know,
eating thing that you do a lot of
physical activity in the range of motion.
Rash guards, good hoodies, good patches,
good regulation size or not
regulations up. Good. All good. Anyway,
what about these mugs, these mugs
better beyond there? Oh yeah, the mugs,
unfortunately.
Uh,
I got a bunch of them made and we sold
them on Amazon and we had a bunch in
stock and then Joe Rogan posted a picture
of his and then they were all gone.
Then they're out of stock. I
got more common, got more kind,
a matte black early March.
I think I tweeted out before
we started the show, just,
just showed the desk with
all the weapons on it,
the amount of testosterone and
jawline in here, national capacity.
There's 30 feet and Jawline,
this office right now.
Uh,
yeah.
But yeah, those, I think what March, right
too. It was like, I think early March.
I think that will be available
for something like that
and still working on the
international for the mugs.
Right? Probably. So, hey,
we're going to make that happen.
So I'm stand by it for that. Also,
k psychological warfare, I like to feel,
sometimes I don't need to sit anymore,
I'm over it. But if you do
need psychological warfare
can't, here's what it is.
You ever have those
days where you're like,
you're about to work out or you have
planned to work up and you're like,
you know, maybe I'll just
work out tomorrow. Everybody
has the absolutely right.
Yes.
So what you do is you get this
album that we put together,
well, it's chocolate talking. I just
kind of recorded it. But like I said,
echo press record better than
anybody else. But it's true.
But it on iTunes you can get like a track.
Like if your thing is like I eat
donuts way too much and you're like,
I'm going to fight the donuts or whatever,
you can just get that track.
It's called what? Sugarcoated
lies. That's for example,
Jockos voice telling you why not to
eat the donut. I love this. Essentially
you don't need to, your voice is so
stern and intense. It curse. It mattered.
Absolutely right.
Yeah. It's like Batman. Yeah, right.
No, I shouldn't Bale Batman personally.
Don't eat the donut. That's more leaf
leis is Batman horse. You're kind of like,
oh no, I'm working joke Joe
something. I Dunno. Either way.
There's a bunch of them though. It's cool.
Like Ted, wake up in the morning. What?
Anyway, it's good man. It helps. It helps
a lot. I very well received. I think so.
Yeah. I was kind of surprised that go
thought it was a good idea and oh man,
people need this.
I'm like,
people need two minutes of me talking
about don't I need it to go work out and
send me in. Like there's no way I
can sleep through cause we want them.
The first track is called wake up and
get after it because I think that really
one of the easiest ways to
start developing discipline
in your life is to wake
up early in the morning.
So the first track is wake up and get
after it and actually do it a count to 10
and give you the
opportunity 10 seconds fair.
And to get out of bed if not out of bed.
By then we've got issues.
Crazy. It's, it's, it's, it's fun. Uh,
anything else along with that? If you
want to get some Jocko white tea. Yeah,
it's available. It's available and
in stock on Amazon. And you know,
before I was hesitant because
at one time I said, hey,
we'll never sell out of it again.
And everybody that listened as podcast
bought it that day and we sold out in 15
minutes cause we sold out the
first time and they're like, no,
I'm just gonna get a ton. I said, don't
worry, guys will never saw it again. Yeah,
we sold out again. Now I'm feeling pretty
confident that we won't sell it again.
If that means I went kind of Richter,
I over engineered the whole thing so we
shouldn't sell out of Jocko white tea
again. You can get it on amazon.com
international orders. Check Ebay.
When you're clicking on Amazon, get
this book right here by Brian. Stan.
Hard for the fight.
You heard him talking about it tonight.
I covered a tiny portion of the book.
Great information about combat,
about leadership and about life.
Definitely check it out. I'll
put it on the website. Yeah,
it'll be on the website access, you
know, boom. It'll be on the website.
And also we were just talking about this.
Got that kid's book coming out.
Uncle Jake,
teaching young mark how to be a
warrior kid instead of a wimpy kid.
Jujitsu. Yeah, pull ups. Yeah.
Studying, yes. Being disciplined.
Yes.
Basically getting after it.
Affirmative age 10 preorder it now,
why not?
If you like this podcast,
100% you will like this book.
I don't care if you're 49 years old,
you will dig this book. I did this book.
I wrote it and I like it.
I like to read it.
My nine year old daughter's reading
it. Oh yeah. Yeah. It's, it's good.
I'll put,
I'll,
I'll leave it at that and I'm not a
person to sit there and say like, oh,
what I did is really good. I don't do
that. I like this book a lot. You know,
you did this really good. Yeah. Uh, also
Leif and I wrote that book right there.
The book called extreme ownership.
You can get it.
We talk about war and we talk about
leadership and we talk about war.
You know, what else would we talk about
if the right one, not one of the spinoffs,
fake rape. Uh, lastly,
extreme ownership muster May 4th and
fifth at the Marriott Marquis in New York
City. Extreme ownership,
mustard number two, by the way,
number one already happened in San Diego.
It was awesome.
This one is going to be awesome.
By the way.
I just had this yet about extreme
ownership muster two. We will be there.
I will be there.
Echo Charles will be there.
We will not be backstage.
We will be.
There is no backstage that we will be up
front. I will be sitting at your table.
We will be talking about things.
Jp Danelle is going to be there as well.
He's going to come and get some. So come
on out to that May 5th, fourth and fifth.
There's a video coming out about it soon.
I warn you that when the video comes
out it's gonna sell out because Echo
Charles makes these videos so persuasive
that everyone's going to come and while
you're waiting for the monster,
you can still carry on this conversation
with us on the interwebs. Yeah,
on Twitter.
On Instagram.
And when you gonna look at
that face book he ball. Huh?
We got to be on that one too.
So Echo is that Echo Charles?
I am at Jocko Willink and
Brian. Stan is at Brian's. Dan,
I keep it simple. I like it. He'd do
it. Two ends on stand. By the way.
Echo Charles, you got any closing
thoughts? That's it man. My man.
Good to meet you and have you for
sure Mr Brian, stamp. Pleasure.
A pleasure and honor.
Thank you so much for having me on and we,
I know we were trying to do this
for probably over a year now.
Well worth it and uh,
you've got a new subscriber.
I get to listen to more of this.
I mean we talk about a lot of things that
we think we already know. Yup. But man,
it's motivating though.
When you continue to hear it,
you continue to hear it and you hear
like minded people out there achieving.
Awesome. Thanks. Thanks for coming on.
And I would like to thank everyone for
listening and we appreciate the support
and the fact more so the fact that you
were out there with us trying to get
better and for those of
you with a uniform on,
especially those overseas right now.
Okay.
Taking the fight to the enemy.
Thank you all for keeping us free
to law enforcement and firefighters.
Thanks to you for keeping us safe.
For those of you that are
just out there on the grind,
working hard and doing good work,
okay.
Go ahead and keep doing that.
Good work.
Okay.
And Brian,
thanks for coming on.
Thanks for your career in the octagon.
Thanks for what you're doing now
with the charity and helping vets.
But most of all, thanks for your
service to this great nation
and to your fellow Marines
who I was always
okay,
humbled to serve alongside.
Thanks to you,
you proud Leathernecks
for your service and sacrifice
and forever upholding your motto.
Semper Fidelis.
Always faithful.
And when we go forward,
each of us,
all of us,
when we go forward in our lives,
let us do so
with the intention of
honoring those brave souls,
those soldiers, sailors, airmen,
and Marines who stood
and held the line
and gave their last full measure
for us.
So until next time,
this is Brian and echo and Jocko
out.